[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and we will ban men
[Music]
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do it
[Music]
jumps
big massive dumpsters
[Music]
[Music]
ducks
[Music]
which is
[Music]
big massive dumpster
[Music]
what is going on here
[Music]
[Music]
boxes
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
absolutely
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right welcome everybody uh oh man am
i muted
no i'm kidding guys i i it's it's not
muted i was just being quiet um welcome
everybody we have
an incredible night ahead of us that was
that's what's called uh we need a name
for that when it's like a fake mute what
would i don't even know what to call
that
uh it's like a trigger mute or something
like that
um welcome everybody i am aware that i'm
in the backup studio today
uh the primary studio exploded and so
i'm in the backup studio today
and there's something about the settings
on my intros where it's muted for the
first few seconds and then there's like
a double audio thing
um
and i don't know what it is it's you
know there's these settings in stream
labs monitor versus monitor and output
and there's multiple different channels
it's really a mess um but in any case
i apologize for any echo
echo
echo that took place the rdo yeah i
should be uh oh no i don't even have
that here hold on do i
the uh trump complaining about the
no i don't everything's all
discombobulated today because because
we're in the backup studio you may
notice that we are monitoring newsmax
rather than right side broadcasting now
you might be saying sir why why are you
doing that
um
and
the reason we are doing that is after
the last rally right side broadcasting
filed a what we call a hard copyright
takedown on our channel
and um
that's very very bad for us
and uh right side broadcasting is
actually aware of us now and i'm gonna
prove that to you in a moment so instead
newsmax will be carrying the rally
um
and that's what's going on but if you're
just joining us
this is from right side broadcasting
earlier today take a listen to this
oh let me take this time to
this something just popped in my head i
did a i did a
a street corner flag wave event
on january 6 down in west palm
and there was a gentleman by the name of
david pac-man at least he's calling me a
gentleman
who was watching us
he's not a fan of us he
he took a clip
of me interviewing a woman who happened
to be asian
i asked her where she was from he took
that clip
to say
that i was asking her where she's from
because she's asian
meaning where are you really from what
he did
was project his own bigotry i asked
everybody where they're from now here's
the thing
i am willing to take the hit
that
i was projecting this network's
political view of anti-immigrant
a sentiment on this guy okay so like
listen we were doing it's called
entertainment and i did say when the guy
was like where are you from i was like
he means where are you really from right
i was projecting this network and this
political movement's xenophobia onto him
which is unfair it's called i was doing
it for the lulls we might say
the pro and i'm willing to cop to that
but the problem is by saying i was
projecting my own bigotry onto him
he's doing that which he accuses me of
doing you guys understand that right
because he's saying
he i don't really know that he's
xenophobic so it was unfair for me to
project that onto him
okay
but he's saying i'm actually xenophobe
but he doesn't know that i'm xenophobic
in fact he has no reason to think that
uh but we made right side broadcasting
guys which is a really really big deal
and especially in a state like florida
duh where we have people from
all over the world all over the country
that move there
you're more likely to find people in
florida from other states than people
that are from florida
i just thought that was interesting you
know we have a lot of fans people that
want to watch us and just to try to try
to smear us but what they're doing is
actually projecting their own views
and their own bigotry
you want an interview
okay so now he gets off off of the topic
of me but so we made it we made it is
the really incredible thing now let me
see if i can get super chats fixed here
uh
so we're gonna go like this
and then
down hold on we've got a new super chat
element ev every week youtube is uh
sort of messing with the super chat
elements so we got it okay good and then
can i switch between them perfect okay
and i'm sorry i missed that last one
we're doing the best we can
david says just read peril by woodward
and costa highly recommend for an
in-depth look at the white house during
the election and transition including
the january 6th coup
very very uh uh highly recommended by
many in fact okay let's let's set the
stage
i promised to you guys that we were
going to have correspondence on the
ground
in conroe texas tonight
where are they well they are there
this is one of the things that we we are
now in the in the thick of it we have
two people on the ground
right now
in texas
and that's luke beasley and josh pitt
they're there right now why aren't we
seeing them the reason we're not seeing
them is
these rallies are held in the middle of
nowhere and they don't even provide
wi-fi for media so
our guys have no signal
luke and josh are there luke beasley has
his own youtube channel he just started
i was excited about promoting it he was
going to be doing content and all these
different things
and there's no there's just no wi-fi
they have it it's a complete
[ __ ] show for lack of a better term so
what we're doing instead
is i've agreed with luke and josh
film what you can and start dumping it
to me via email
and um
maybe that that will allow us to um to
air some of it just dump the video like
via dropbox or whatever and what
happened if you
they call them dumps exactly
so the guys are on the ground there and
we're doing the best we can um and so i
think in the future what we probably
should have is some kind of system where
i send them like the back there's these
backpacks but the problem is the
backpacks depend on the same 4g 5g
that their phones depend on so i don't
know that it actually does anything for
us unfortunately
unfortunately we'd have to figure that
out
we'd have to figure that out but they're
gonna try to get me some stuff
um
and and
as soon as we can we'll have that to you
so they are there welcome everybody we
are it is another rally night in the
united states of america
um
we are
awaiting donald trump in conroe texas
and anticipating announcements and lies
and we have video from there that we're
going to look at we're going to be
looking at a whole bunch of different
things so i'm so glad that you're here
before i fall too far behind
let me just thank everybody who has
signed up to support us so far
and first and foremost i want to thank
brian smith for signing up on my website
and matthew robertson for signing up on
my website those are new members one and
two and as you can see we have gone to
two
and one of those uh individuals used the
coupon code obama obama and that's much
appreciated also want to thank everybody
over on twitch who has been supporting
and that includes
huge the huge
beth graham slingblade
harry
dirtnap
poorly wiped sapien
life is good
jen here is number eight
alice marabiyas is number nine robot
laser party
david krappenshitz is number 11. weather
boxer and spunky
that's 13
13 plus 2 is 15 by my account and that
uh already sets us up
very very strongly for today so i will
thank everybody
um okay other super chats coming in not
too much right now uh but uh okay let's
start getting at
a couple looking at a few uh different
things here
this was um this was pretty funny
someone got in to uh some kind of local
media when marjorie taylor green
was uh
taking calls i guess
and uh they told her that she's a
disgrace and i loved it hello
go ahead
to say um
god for joe biden
she is an embarrassment to the state of
georgia
well we all have our opinions
all righty thank you so that was a hero
caller
absolute and total hero caller
do you guys hear that what is that noise
very weird
um so that's that
um recently our friend
hassan [ __ ]
had christian walker over at his house
christian walker is the son correct me
if i'm wrong of herschel walker herschel
walker is a former nfl player currently
running for senate i don't even know
that what i'm saying is true but i
believe herschel walker's running for
senate
his son christian walker
is part of the i guess he's part of the
gay conservative movement
and he raided me i was raided by
christian walker he evaluated me
let's listen i think david
who
he's a hell now oh
ranking me hell no
and what i
that is like a bad photo okay most of
these photos are bad hold on let me just
show you first of all dave reuben not at
all
uh not for me i'm i've met him i really
like him all that i okay you can you can
you don't have to answer this if you
don't want to what
hassan what are you gonna ask are you a
top or bottom or verse oof
um i like a big masculine man and i am
not is this like hassan's regular show
the first one or the last one so what
what does that mean is it top bottom
reverse i'm not the first oh okay not a
good option okay all right like don't
ask this stupid question like that like
everybody knew and then they already
knew hey you know what i absolutely love
as some of you know there is another
david pakman and it's this guy here and
this guy here i know i know him i've
known him for a long time a venture
capitalist
uh from uh uh venrock and you know
anyway it's just funny that they're also
looking at pictures of the other david
bachman who's like 55.
like
it's so dumb no i mean listen i don't
know people and people love to like
someone made a fake grinder profile of
me and was like
oh like i just want a big strong
american white man first of all i like
my man latino in middle eastern and okay
anyway i think we're gonna get off of
this but
uh it's all
very very dumb so i was ranked very low
extremely low i came in at a very low
ranking which i will take uh obama
prompt oh hold on let me see if i have
that obama
[Music]
then he went donald trump yeah
okay obama prompt says david sir thank
you for doing these events live i think
it's important to pay attention so we
don't forget the dangers of trumpism but
i wouldn't be able to watch it without
you thank you obama prompt zachary says
david i think it's important we have a
conversation about trumpy bear i agree
desiree dewitt says it's our one year
anniversary david i've loved and hated
every moment of it mostly loved you
mostly hated what you were covering it's
been it's been quite a year and jack
says david sir have you seen sam cedar's
debate with jackson hinkle absolutely
nothing to learn from it other than the
brain rot of the jimmy dore types who is
jackson hinckle i don't know does
anybody know who that is
i'm not aware of jackson hinkle
nobody knows no
adore acolyte i didn't know door haddock
accolades to be perfectly frank
okay very good uh let me also say huge
thank yous to palm top noble st james
sam the sleazebag and margot cabot for
the twitch prime subs putting us at 19
for the day okay i have a i have a
voicemail for you guys apparently
someone went and got them the citrus i
recommended and they had some kind of a
problem listen to this
hey david it's derek from math oh
this is fake eric from mass eric from
mass is the anti-vaxx guy who calls in
and like last week he said soon they're
going to be closing the vaccines it'll
be closed for business this is a parody
of eric from mass
just want to let you know
the fda is coming out with a report in
the next couple of days
about tatsumas
turns out they're not the best citrus at
all not even close
not those
satsuma sumo wrestler oranges or
whatever either
it's actually the tangelo
it's got a nipple on top and everything
right billions of people have already
died
intense tumors and
choking on the peels you can look it up
anyway just wanted to warn you before
you go live again and make yourself look
like a fool exactly
so a very very um important warning
there
i may have to actually
there's been so much snow plow trucks
are going by
and it gets very hot in the room
so i've got the window open
and it's a lot of different things going
on if you're having sync issues just
refresh the stream
here's a nice message of peace and love
from the dog whistling yodeler who says
you're gorgeous david don't let the
conservative gays bring you down
and we will ban men
jeremiah says david did you know the art
of the deal was the first book like
literal book not book but idea or was it
library i'm a big book big idea guy hey
that that reminds me
i have um
i've been just just as a goof
i've been tweeting some jordan peterson
like fake jordan peterson stuff
so like last night just as a joke i
tweeted
music is about patterns and they talk
about flying the pattern in aviation and
so airplanes actually fly based on
musical scales taking off is a middle c
landing an f sharp etc yet they don't
talk about this now this is obvious
satire
i want to show you guys some of the
responses where people people actually
thought
there's one in particular
that's so
funny uh by the way this is really good
argyle is a pattern invented in scotland
patterns are everything the scotland is
in fact everything
um
but there was one where it's like come
on guys this is obviously a joke
uh
where was it it's like amazing
some people thought i just lost my mind
this man is a genius yeah
uh people not realizing he's doing
peterson oh i love this this one i like
you might say the g6 is a plane but
actually the g6 technically speaking is
a chord
that is complicated that is complicated
uh where is the guy that thought i was
totally for real
i might not even be able to find it
who exactly is they
maybe the person deleted it
birds you should invite them on
now okay i can't find it anyway i was
just trying to communicate information
to you guys so that's that's all it was
so we took care of that
and we took care of this one and this
one and we'll get to a couple of other
things very soon
thanks again to dog whistling yodeler i
do want to say thank you to yes
gregerson for signing up on my website
with the coupon code obama obama your
new member number 20 today as you can
see right above my head and i encourage
others
uh there is a user who grabbed the
twitch prime subscription but their
username is so vile i can't even i can't
even read it
because there are some kids watching so
we'll just say that that's number 21.
rally starting in about 45 minutes
everybody everybody relax we have we
have plenty to do all right let's get to
some
do you guys want to do
video from the rally first
or do you want to do other other like
miscellaneous videos first
i'm willing to do either we're going to
do both
um
thanks to through the looking glace
for the twitch prime subscription as
well miscellaneous and then we'll build
to rally i think that that makes sense
actually let me see if i can get that
going uh okay here's a special video
this is sherry 10 penny she goes by
doctor i believe she is hold on a second
let me i don't want to
whenever i misstate
people's credentials in this world i get
attacked
she is an anti-vaxx osteopath who
believes
vaccines cause autism
magnetize people
and connect people
with a cell phone
tower uh okay so that's i'm not that's
not a value judgment i'm just telling
you who
and what she is
okay so everybody just relax
let's take a listen to what she had to
say this is this is quite an
announcement
remember this term because you're going
to hear a lot of it in the next year
quantum entanglement right i believe
deepak chopra uses that term quantum
entanglement because when that's from a
physics perspective what happens when
you take that shot in there's all this
entangling that's on and with the
artificial intelligence actually i got
my some while while i got my booster
someone tied my shoelaces together and i
got completely tangled up leaving the
cvs intelligence hooking you up to the
google credit scores and all the you
know all of the the d ma the d matrix
and all of those things i've been d
matrixed in fact every time i have uh
fruit
i feel like i'm dematrixed it's
happening in people that are already
been injected so what you need to do is
really understand what their endgame is
and block it and repent and stand back
trust and truth and lead into the lord
and then that is your salvation that's
dr 10 penny now i'm almost positive
chopra
quantum like i know chopra uses the word
quantum a lot let's see here
um
quantum healing he often says
frequently in uh
you know that's that's 45 minutes now
let's see if we can find something
that's
chopra quantum
because that's sounding very chopra like
to me
i guess i don't have a good example of
it here
i do want to let you guys know that we
are working on a new game
the game is going to be called
peterson or chopra
and the way it's going to work is our
team is working on this my colleague
john is is working on this
i'm going to put up a we'll do it during
a stream i'm going to put up a text
quote so we won't hear it we'll we'll
read it
and
we will have to determine whether the
quote is a jordan peterson quote or a
deepak chopra quote and then we'll you
know like for content and engagement you
know we'll do like a poll
and then we'll actually have a video
clip
of uh either jordan peterson or deepak
chobra i think they're incredibly
they're increasingly indistinguishable
so i think it's a great uh i think i
think it's going to be a really really
good game uh look forward to playing it
with everybody
all right i do want to say thanks to ann
rallison for using the coupon code obama
on my website
and also dustin strait just signed up
with the coupon code obama obama new
members 23 and 24 also want to say a
brutally huge thank you we're actually
we're actually seeing uh
oh there's a big uh big twitch dump of
memberships
dumps
lc rich bird nation indubitabled
lily
numeral whistle
hajil
and
guiamiavia
have all signed up via twitch prime
uh welcome everybody thank you we are we
are just moments away from this uh
trump rally
let me see what other non-trump rally
stuff i have
oh this is pretty clever as well i think
you guys might like this this is one of
these anti-mask
extremists
made into a musical
this is really really good
i am a woman of god
this is my right as much as it is yours
this is my land as much as history i did
not sign up for this i am a christian
woman of god and you are not going to
put your disgusting news on me that are
false and not true i will not have it
you understand that i will not have it
i'm sick of being bullied i'm sick of
being lied to and it's not gonna happen
anymore do you understand
the cdc just released
oh my gosh oh my gosh
oh my gosh
oh i didn't even realize she got
arrested at the end that actually makes
it perfect
um
man that's really good this reminds me
of how would i be able to find
do you guys remember at the rnc the girl
who sang
the anthem and it was a complete and
total train wreck and then someone did
the chord changes on a piano
um
rnc anthem
piano let's see if i can find that
um
convention anthem piano damn how let me
see
republican national convention
national anthem piano it's kind of like
a piano remix oh oh my god i found it
right away
check this out this this it's the same
sort of concept here
hold on a second
yeah this is the idea
[Applause]
this is the best
[Music]
see
by the dawn's
early light
what so
proudly we
[Music]
whose broad stripes and bright stars
[Music]
[Music]
okay you guys get it you guys get the
concept but it's a really it's a very
good concept it's a very very good
concept
um okay i want oh
i'm sorry for the people that were
having uh dinner well while we played
that
um
oh hold on one of our moderators has
just sent me a heavy metal version let's
just just to be thorough i want to make
sure we're not missing
[Music]
you are the people in history
[Music]
man
wow that that's pretty serious uh okay
good
so i think i i do think we have all the
bases covered as far as as far as that's
concerned thank you to john verderie
and james pugh both who just signed up
on my website with the coupon code obama
obama also want to say thanks over on
twitch to snappy tam
who says i'm also a website member but
couldn't think of a better use of my
bezos bucks
thanks for the entertainment i
appreciate that
um
oh okay people are asking what are some
of the origins of some of these clips
okay that's fair
so this clip obama the origins of that
one are
actually it's kind of hard
let's see if i can find it
whoops
okay here's the origin of obama
obama
oh that's not
okay
that that that was not it um
damn
i used to have it on my soundboard but
now i don't
obama
original
let's see
oh here it is
okay here's the origin these are the
oranges of obama if ted doesn't win your
second amendment is going to be in
trouble big trouble remember that
o'rourke voted against the border wall
oh that's a good thing to him he voted
against kate's law and he voted for
obama there it is amnesty so that's that
one then this one and we will ban men
that's just from two weeks ago
um
and i don't even know if i if i have the
original on that
trump ban men
yeah i don't even have that one
no that is a good one though and we will
ban men some of these are just at this
point part of the milieu you know
cephei
cepha high it's like you don't even need
they're just they're ubiquitous i guess
i would say
um okay
very good
let's um let's continue and let me get
to
some super chats laura asks are we
waiting for another big announcement
that will not happen of course
of course laura no question about it
sabine with today's top super chat says
absolutely love your channel lots of
love from indiana
and then wizard of frabas says i know
some anti-vaxxers claim they're putting
something nefarious in the vaccines if
the government were going to do that
they'd put in something they all take
annually without blinking duh
right
right
that's exactly right
uh i it's hard to disagree with such a
statement it really is all right let's
go over to some um
oh hold on something happening at the
let's let's actually listen to what
they're talking about here who share a
1200 mile long border with mexico
where biden is failing to act republican
leaders though like the texas governor
are left to pick up the slack the new
york times reports that more than 2 500
migrants have been arrested so they're
doing immigration stuff dion says love
your show you're the man grab another
audio clip all right let's do we'll do
one more
uh
how about this one by the way how are
the calzones right that is from the
written house trial that was the judge
uh let's see if i can find the
video of it that one i should be able to
do
uh no i'm not okay
what was that guy's name what was a
schroeder
i i can't even it's it's crazy it's like
hard to find them
judge schroeder calzones
uh
yeah i like can't even find them it's
it's crazy
it's it's like they just disappear into
the ether and then they're only
preserved on our uh
on our soundboard tragically enough
mini says david you were handsome thank
you wow what a
what an evening
you know what i really should have
actually as far as that goes
see if i can find it
um let me see sound board i am just not
as prepared as i should be
where do i have that
is it under miscellaneous
yeah oh here it is i should have my alex
jones impression on my soundboard
because that can actually be relevant at
almost any time
see here
globalist internationalist trotskyite
socialist shun like obama trudeau macron
and the rest of these zio beasts
right
bull freak knot says who was the
republican that lost it when the young
girl asked him a question i saw the clip
but i don't know who it was so it was
dan crenshaw but correct me if i'm wrong
wasn't it a joke that the girl was only
10 years old i thought someone yelled
it's a 10 year old but it wasn't really
a 10 year old right
wasn't that the deal
it was not a joke
oh i thought it was
okay
um
david long-term fan from the uk wanted
to show support for what you do always
fantastic commentary keep up the good
work thank you uh william i really
appreciate that
thank you very much and also thanks to
jay tandoway for re-upping the twitch
prime subscription number 35 today
all right let's go to
a few um
you know against my better judgment i
guess we should
just have access to the live right side
stream even though they dumped a uh
copyright claim on us just just so we
can track it all right let's look at
some videos from the rally there's some
wacky wacky stuff here um first let's
look at
uh
ron philpkowski who does a great great
job during the rally trump tried to sell
books they played a video of trump
encouraging people to buy his book
let's listen to the uh
to the announcement going on stage right
now i look forward to being with you
very soon and i want to thank you for
your incredible support your amazing
people so many of you have asked me
where can you purchase our new book
nobody has asked that
absolutely nobody is asking that these
people don't read
like it's not even plausible that these
people were asking where to buy a book
our journey together
it's something very special it's done
really well
it's not easy to get it's available for
purchase right here at the rally
so you can take it home with you today
get your copy now before it runs out
again
i love you all we're gonna have a great
time together i'll see you in a little
while there it is
and we will ban men so trump selling
books there
um let me see what else we have from the
rally there was just a lot of stuff
um
i don't want to do that one
okay here's a
here's some kind of flat earth i guess
thing
everybody's happy
and everybody's got one goal and that's
for everybody to love everybody
and
lurari i can't even say that what is
that that's not a texas accent the texas
accent actually i like it has sort of
some charm and coherence what what
accent is this do we know
i i need to listen to how would we even
spell that phonetically to love
everybody
and um save our save our country live
their best lives
unpopular opinion i'm a flat earther so
uh
like i just been talking to some people
today telling them why i believe what i
believe
it's like i try to find common ground on
uh because most people would agree that
we don't come from oh wait a second guys
i hate to interrupt this
uh
we have two people
we have two people on the ground today
in texas
because they've not provided any wi-fi
for media
our team luke beasley and josh pitt are
are trying to record clips and send them
to me
apparently luke just spoke to someone
who admits he was at the capitol on
january 6. we we may be able to deliver
a heretofore unknown
new defendant to the fbi
uh i'm trying to see if we can get this
video this this could be potentially
breaking news that 725 defendants could
be become 726 defendants momentarily uh
let me see if there's gonna be any way
the team is in charge in touch with me
very strongly right now
what a stupid song [ __ ]
yes having a hard time sending it with
bad cell guy just admitted to me he was
at the capitol on january 6th
oh man we need that video
uh let me know if you get it uploaded
etc
wow
uh
it's like they've been there ten minutes
and we have a new we have a new criminal
defendant potentially uh what what an
incredible situation you gotta get that
relayed to me i wanna say thanks to
chris shofel who just signed up on my
website joinedpakman.com and his new
member number 36 today using the coupon
code obama obama um all right let's
continue with flat earth dude monkeys
and that we didn't big bang right hold
on something about monkeys i want to
hear that and common ground on uh
because most people would agree that we
don't come from monkeys and that we
didn't big bang right so if you guys
this guy is definitely not big banging
ever i can assure you guys
this is not an individual who's who's
big banging you can find common ground
with people then you can start building
a foundation of like what truth is you
know
so once we establish that this guy's not
big banging we didn't come from monkeys
and the earth is flat at that point we
would have a baseline
for
uh so-called truth yeah exactly all
right
um so that guy's there here's a woman
who was at kewanon
so that's what all this is
love it is this your first trump rally
no sir i went to um
uh tulsa oklahoma in april
and it was uh freedom fest and clay
clark's reawaken america tour
and it was about educating people that
some of the ideas that we're going
through need to be researched a little
deeper right there's way too much false
information false and you need to
educate yourself on health
and obviously the people i go to when i
when i'm looking for the truth you know
we can all
feel around for what might be the truth
when i'm ready for the truth i go and
find someone with a novelty oversized
poster board of trump's face
and that's where i start establishing
the truth and i think it's only natural
that we all do that that that makes a
lot of sense to me yourself on your
water educate yourself on what you put
in your body
and that's a personal choice
that they should not have the right to
take that away from us no water is a
really really big thing people are
flushing toilets 10 times 15 times
exactly okay
so it's a pretty normal one
uh this guy says don't listen to the
media okay that's that's fine
um
here's a woman who says basically she
lived for trump's tweets and she's
wearing a box okay
he was kicked off twitter i mean i miss
those tweets do you what are you doing
every single day of my life that's what
i spent doing for five years right
literally i mean it's everything i did
and i miss them terribly and the people
miss them terribly that's the sad thing
woman in a box lived for trump's tweets
throw him the hell out of here please
um
guy at the trump rally shows off a you
are fake news shirt
okay
outfit of the day you are fake news all
right all right if you were to watch the
news who do you watch if you don't say
rsbn
rsbn first
newsmax second right
fox news third all right fair enough you
know what i do that's it
he's being honest
guy at the trump rally tells interviewer
to do research on how oh i don't even i
want to this seems crazy enough that i
just want to hear it do your research on
this right here the world economic forum
klaus schwab this is bigger than trump
this is bigger than any of us is bigger
than any politician look in the
background there's someone with a mass
formation psychosis sign too
this is a global plan to enslave you and
your family and pretty much make you
poor and dependent upon a global
government
something i like to call evil so it's
even bigger than that no spiritual
warfare right now i think it's written
about in this book it's a really popular
book uh a lot of people read it i think
the bible bible revelation right you
can't buy or sell without the mark kind
of like in new york you can't i got to
tell you guys i don't know what the hell
revelation is like
i've been doing this show for so long
and i've had guests tell me that they
know something to be true because of
revelation
is is revelation a book or is it a
library
know
it's the last book of the bible
now is the history of the physical book
revelation the same as the history of
the text in
it i'm trying to figure that out that's
tough
uh woman says we're living under a
satanic system
that is pure evil good versus evil it's
not left right it's not democrat and i
believe that too right now you know what
i'm saying i'm saying i think i think
this um uh uh system that we got going
on right now is a satanic system uh
system right and let me tell you
something and let me tell you something
i believe i believe satan is on his
j.o.b man he is on his j-o-b and we need
to be getting on with our j-o-b we got
to take this crunchy back for god man to
get back from god or for god did she say
that's weird oh god man she seems to say
take it from god um with rjob we got to
take this crunchy back for god man does
she say for or from can anybody tell
for god oh okay
okay okay okay
all right
we got to take this country back for
jesus christ man
amen yes darkness can only exist in the
absence of light so we must shine a
light shine the light of truth yes yes i
all right so really really good job by
ron phillipkowski's team covering this
stuff now then we go over to the patriot
takes crew
and
it's potentially even crazier uh there
are confederate flags at uh for sale at
the rally
this woman believes that the current joe
biden is fake
current joe biden is fake
why why are you here supporting trump
what's your motivation he's our real
president thank you very much and what
what what are you basing that on what
the fact that the election was stolen
and he's our real president
is fake and he's the real biden was
assassinated at gitmo in 2019 march of
2019. so what's on this
that's obvious guys i mean it's like how
would you
how how how has anyone been tricked into
thinking that that didn't happen
i
i agree with you with the part that
there's no way those demanding machines
they've already been proven all over the
world
what was crooked the dominion chains but
trump's having 40 50 60 000 people at
his rallies before
he is where is trump having 60 000
people at a rally i don't even know that
presidency
or for the election and biden has 50
people and that includes
the people there for security and the
media all together and he supposedly got
more votes than obama correct so
how do you explain that because the
american people know who we're really
president is we're fighting for america
and we are going to
save this country and the world
and people know that uh if i did the
pedophile and they don't want to go see
it because they know he's a pedophile
come on creepy joe
creepy joe's the pedophile
very very sick people guys very very
sick um all right i'm gonna step away
for five minutes refill my water close
this window as we get ready we're gonna
listen to don junior and i'll be back in
five
and then there was this strange this
strange four-year pause
right
it was a strange four-year-old and we
were ourselves
right
right russia wasn't taking over and
that's just a little bit of what um don
jr is there as he uh continues to fire
up the crowd and it is a very serious
issue what is going on right now between
russia and ukraine and u.s involvement
whether or not we will send troops there
to some of the neighboring nato nations
there in europe lots of folks concerned
about that yeah and i think he also
mentioned too uh how divisive we've seen
this country i mean goodness gracious
even to try to get something bipartisan
through
uh congress is very difficult to do we
saw the bipartisan infrastructure bill
but the president's own build back
better agenda uh that's not getting
passed he's gonna have to break it up in
order to get it through and then of
course the voting right legislation bill
as well that was a major topic of
conversation uh also did not pass and of
course the filibuster remaining in place
right so the separation not just between
republicans and democrats but within the
democratic party themselves they can't
come to some sort of agreement now
we're going to i believe go back to
texas uh where john bachman is there and
i think john is going to talk to the
lieutenant governor uh dan patrick
john are you there
that is correct heather i'm standing
here i am here heather we're here with
lieutenant governor dan patrick just got
off the stage great speech you got the
crowd fired up one of the things you
mentioned though you said the 45th and
47th president i'm sure you saw that
video clip didn't yeah yes i did i had
lunch with the president today we had a
little gathering of about a dozen of us
and i was his campaign manager in 16 and
20 here in texas and so we got our our
group together and i had heard about the
clip and then it came up today and i
said mr president
45-47
it sounds like you've already kind of
that's right yeah what else you know and
look this is the biggest
red county in america a county of more
than 100 000 people or more with the
highest support for trump over 70
percent and these people are just
this is trump country all right welcome
back everybody
i am uh i i am still here and we just
have so much going on that uh oh i'm
sorry and i've been let's get to some of
these super chats matthew says jackson
hinkle debated sam cedar this week
marxist leninist anti-imperialist
patriot the squad will bring fascism
appears to be a new left grifter appeals
to the right wing door audience crazy
making wow
wow
that's wild
revelation was a letter to the church
apocalyptic literature with symbolic
messaging for christians persecuted
under the roman empire to be faithful in
the meantime
yikes
and jack says david sir did you see
candace owens tweet that she believes
the moon landing was fake yes
yes
um
i did see that very very sick woman
how's the vegetable garden doing
well it's winter it's totally dead
i did plant winter garlic though so
we'll see what pops up
a thanks to sophia d for signing up on
my website with the coupon code obama
and thanks to matthew campbell for
signing up on my website with the coupon
code obama obama um we are standing by
for donald trump but presumably just uh
moments away at this point in time
and uh also thanks to 420 weed bong
as well as grim reaper
small fuzzy moss lb kiwi snoochie buchi
lady to groan dinan cleo tight bot
as well
uh okay
let me see if i have any more news
from anybody down in texas we do so for
people let me see if i'm getting any
stuff
you so if you're just joining us some of
you might remember that we had this idea
of sending correspondence down to the
rally
and we have two great people there right
now luke beasley who has a youtube
channel you can find
and josh pitt
the wi-fi is so bad
that
they're they're being relegated to just
recording stuff and then they're gonna
try to send it to me and we just heard
from luke
that he spoke to someone who admits to
having been at the capitol on january
6th so it's all pretty insane yeah they
provide no wi-fi for media
uh and we were not equipped to bring our
own satellite truck i must say
revelation says everyone will be
required to get a mark from the devil
and no one can buy or sell without it
much of the christian anti-vaxx movement
is because of this bs yeah
it's creepy when they talk about trump
as if he's holding the office of the
presidency he's a petty king pretending
pretender trying to enforce a claim with
an army
it is weird when they insist like trump
is currently the president yeah
yeah uh all right let's get back to some
of our patriot takes clips
let's see what else they've got
oh here's actually the the candace owens
conspiracy thing
mine is the moon landing was faked i
don't know why anyone listens to
anything she says i really don't
um
okay and i guess that's it there let's
see if ron's team got anything new for
us
this is trump arriving i guess
[Applause]
oh my god
it's like the covet ride
uh that's a weird hat huh
oh canada oh my god now i understand the
hat that's so weird now i get it this is
from the canadian thing
got it geez that's bizarre
okay all right so we are we are very
very close to uh
the start of the start of this rally
thank you very much everybody other
super chats coming in hey david do
twitch donors show up for you wanted to
ask when will trump show up tonight
under five minutes late more than 10 etc
and can we make it a twitch prediction
yes moderators please do a twitch
prediction will trump be
i would set the over under at 15 minutes
will trump be more or less than 15
minutes late tonight
maybe moderators could set that up on
twitch and potentially youtube as well i
think that's a good idea
um
david after the jordan peterson disaster
i think you'd get a kick out of tim
heideker's 11 hour joe rogan parody you
don't have to watch more than a minute
to get the shtick yeah i i've seen it
um
let's see i'll we'll pull up a little
clip for people who haven't
because it is pretty funny
rogan
see if i can find it here
here's like 30 seconds of it and you'll
get the picture very quickly
uh
uh i should say we've got uh rashad
suresh here i'm saying that correct i
don't want to be disrespectful no no no
no no
cancel mob is gonna come down your
throat man
dude they will they will no that's for
real that's for real though yeah yeah
like if i don't get that right on the
money the first time around that that's
it like oh my gosh [ __ ] that i will get
the [ __ ] that i will have to get yeah
man for that it's gotten crazy out there
it's
crazy
all right let's look at like another
random random moment from it
uh i don't know let's just pick like
here
god
i mean you got we mentioned ken collins
i mean r.i.p ken collins you said today
though yeah so yeah i mean r.a.p
i just saw this morning um
uh
kyle maxim
205
million views on his latest wow holy
[ __ ] that guy and that just came out
like two days ago that guy's alleged i'm
so happy is it actually 11 hours of
original content or does stuff repeat
like how could they do this
man because i remember him from back
when we were just like hitting open mics
together man nicest dude comes out
nicest dude you got it have you seen
this have you seen the special have you
seen it i haven't seen it yet i haven't
seen it i haven't seen it yet no
i have it cued up on my uh
tab
is it good dude
dude comes out yeah and he's like
ripped like okay anyway i think you guys
got you get the picture this it just it
repeats from there
um
okay all right we are standing by for
donald trump donald trump jr currently
speaking
and a lot of very very crazy things are
going on let me see if our
correspondents have anything new for me
they are trying to upload video to me
um
from texas
listen if we if we don't get the video
in time for today's rally we'll have it
for the monday show from our team in
texas and that
that's a great thing i want to say
thanks to decomposing diva diva and c
missile for the twitch prime
subscriptions if you're just tuning in
we are now just moments moments away
from the donald trump rally
uh scheduled for
the top of the hour we've already seen
video of donald trump arriving don jr
continuing to speak
they're like what's going on here i
don't understand
if you're a male kindergarten teacher
and you want to take paternity leave i
think it's wonderful i couldn't care
less
if you're the secretary of
transportation you get your ass to work
it's not that hard a concert when
millions tens of millions hundreds of
millions of people depend on you just so
p i i'm seeing in the ch it's so it's
it's actually
it's heartwarming to see in the chat
people who have not
done these rallies with us and are
shocked that like
there's obviously strategically placed
people on the stage
the blacks for trump people are here you
know cops for trump you're shocked at
how stupid the pablum is and the fact
that don jr seems to be shot out of a
cannon
uh
it's it's like it's really heartwarming
to know that there are people who aren't
aware that this this is what it is and
how completely insane it is
um
there is something about that that's
quaint i guess i would say oh okay let's
see here
uh oh i've just gotten a video from our
team
in uh in texas hold on a second
let's see what we got okay guys now i'm
about to play we have a team in texas
guys
i'm gonna play the first clip
i'm taking a risk oh there's there's a
finally updated okay
okay great pulling it up now
i don't know what we're about to see
and we all are gonna be looking at this
together
okay let me just
make sure everything's good before we
go a little too crazy this is a global
exclusive
um
oh and i'm glad to see uh okay here we
go i'm glad to see luke wearing wearing
a mask down there around these people
let's see what this is about
so you're here at the trump rally what
are you opening here from him
on stage
you know i just wanna i hope we have a
plan to get this uh get our republic
back that's what i'm here for i'm trying
to find my son he's in this big crowd
here
we were
in washington on january 6th with two
million patriots
and i'm happy to be here i walked about
three miles hold on were there two
million people at the insurrection two
million is that what the guy just said
there's there were two million people i
gotta hear that again
two million patriots what that what the
hell is he talking about
they were there okay
and i'm happy to be here i walked about
three miles to get to this field well
just just wait till you try to leave sir
dang tell me to go from the rally to the
capitol
[Music]
oh boy we are going to have to get this
over to the fbi just to see we if if
this is a potential defendant of course
law enforcement needs to know about that
oh my goodness yeah that's crazy no it
was uh it was a it was a great day until
the end
probably 2 million
oh my god guys
holy [ __ ]
um
that's luke beasley guys make sure you
check out luke beasley who's on the
ground for us
uh on youtube
um let me just find that we he's doing a
hell of a job down there
um
he only has uh a thousand subscribers
right now this is luke beasley's channel
it's just youtube.com luke beasley
he uh he's down there for us
so uh yeah if you guys want to send that
to tips at fbi.gov that's that's totally
fine
but yeah that's certainly someone that
they should they should be looking into
okay very good
um
let me just
amazing okay
all right so luke doing
doing a hell of a job down there
uh all right amazing
it's hard to even keep up with it all i
want to say thanks to paul grove who
just signed up on my website join
joinpackman.com using the coupon code
obama
uh and that is number 48 today number 48
today and we really appreciate everybody
joining us yeah luke beasley guys luke
beasley and wow he just got
hold on what one thousand two hundred
one point one more did he just get a
couple hundreds of i don't even know i'm
having trouble doing math but that's
really really great stuff excellent
excellent stuff there um okay
uh thanks to canned caviar also for the
twitch prime subscription putting us at
49 presumably about a 10
10 um minutes from donald trump let's
listen to a little more of junior
[Applause]
let's go brandon
all right
they're all saying it think about it
name a cultural phenomenon like that
chant all over college campuses all over
sports stadiums all of these places that
the left controls at the top right
they're all saying it they're losing the
narrative folks
cepha
they're all saying it barely will never
be covered equally we'll always be
suppressed but they hear it and they get
it so we have to turn out in numbers
like you've never seen before and say
enough is enough
enough of what i mean these are the best
love being here
i love you all
thank you
[Applause]
there he goes
[Music]
so off goes donald trump jr
and donald
donald trump will be next as we continue
to keep an eye on the pre-show
uh and the entire thing um you haven't
missed anything i guess if you're just
joining us in in a sense in a sense you
haven't missed anything
if you're just joining us
via super chat larry says not sure if
ivanka is even old enough but it can't
be this snow fiend don jr or simple eric
upholding the frump name right no
absolutely not
if ivanka weren't my daughter perhaps
i'd be dating her and that's part of why
that's part of why i can't be counting
on i can't can't be counting on her
absolutely
uh will i do ymca when trump takes the
stage maybe i don't know
that stupid country song they plays is
kind of a big part of the atmospherics i
guess i would say
okay
let's um let's let's continue
uh i i highly doubt trump would announce
his candidacy even if it's his intention
um because
if he did
i believe there's something about his
fundraising that would get
significantly more um complicated
canned caviar says david thank you for
acknowledging my twitch sub please
answer a non-political question do you
ever drink basque cider no
i know you have family and visit
cantabria
no i've never been to cantabria
i don't know what this person is talking
about
oh hold on pillow millions of you out
there my employees and i want to
personally thank each and every one of
you for all your support at my pillow we
have hundreds of products now including
my new slippers
okay indistinguishable from parody um
guys you know i don't know what you're
talking about i don't have family in
cantabria
i don't have anything in sargadowa i
don't even know what country that's in
sargadowa is that italy
yeah i'm not even sargoda
is in pakistan i don't know what this
guy's talking about no i'm not pakistani
i i'm sorry i don't know can caviar
appreciate your support have no idea
what you're talking about thanks to
joykit as well for the twitch prime
subscription putting us at 50
and also thanks to kenny molina for
signing up on my website joinpakman.com
let me mention once and not again i'm
gonna mention it once and we'll see how
mentioning it once works
i would love it
if you got a membership on my website
right now if just one percent of the ten
thousand people watching right now did
this
it would be the best night we've had in
probably a year
uh as you know we were banned for 90
days from facebook modernization we were
able to recover it after 15 thanks to a
bunch of facebook employees who watch
the show we've had periods where we lose
all of our youtube revenue you guys know
about twitch and tv and what happens
there we've lost all our revenue there
so
when people sign up on our website it
just takes us out of that whole game and
we can do things like uh having people
down at the rally
interviewing trumpists like we do today
and all of these different things so
head on over to joinpakman.com we have
multiple coupon codes the one above me
obama
is a very large discount you can also
use the coupon code sad trump
that's
it
that one's such a big discount that some
of the southern states you've got to be
careful attorneys general they're not
thrilled with that discount but i will
shout out everybody who signs up
everybody who signs up will get a shout
out and uh of course if you're watching
on twitch and you've got amazon prime
you can use your twitch prime
subscription it costs you nothing and it
takes five bucks from jeff bezos without
violating hipaa or giraffe or rhino or
any of these different things
um
okay so let's get to some other super
chats here
david the wonder of social media my
cousin worked the most wanted list for
the fd fbi before retirement he already
has the clip i feel good wow that's
serious david pakman 2028 no i can never
be president because i was not born here
uh hello david sir am i a jerk for not
signing a get well soon card for a
co-worker who's on oxygen
at the hospital he's anti-vaxx mask maga
that is a very personal question i
couldn't possibly answer
could not possibly answer that
um it was antifa's brother
has just grabbed a twitch prime
subscription so has mulekay
bloody bean gaming
luftkan as well
putting us at 55
very much appreciate that
do will i am i willing to play a whitney
voicemail
if another person gets a membership i'll
just do it right now here's a whitney
voicemail for you guys
so i was wondering if you knew that like
everybody in the media is actually
jewish
you know whitney i've never heard any
um anti-semitic conspiracies about
jewish control of media this this is the
this is the first i've heard about it
i should really try to learn learn more
that's that's interesting no i didn't
know about that
um
is that something people talk about if
people mentioned that before i'm not
sure
okay
um let's see what else i've got as far
as voicemail i don't know that we want
to do voicemails right now it's kind of
a downer to be totally honest
uh
david pakman on your program i noticed
you failed to report
and as did the other big four news
networks
refuse to report
uh last weekend's massive
anti-vaccine rally oh give me a break
the rally was on a saturday my first
show was on a monday and like the first
segment of the show
on monday was about the rally
it's
we need to get rid of the pond scum guys
we really do
we just received a
massive dump of memberships on the
website let me say thank you to the
following people
jesse bealhardt
tiger harris
xander ensland
tabitha speaks
christopher prevost harrison baum
ian kirkpatrick emily shaw
um
paris dabao or debo
christopher johnson
edward lee
and dustin moss all signing up with the
coupon code obama obama that's 12
putting us at 67.
before i move on i also want to thank oh
my goodness look at this
tiffany hall julie barath jane gass
tiffany sims
trent rodrigue
remington buckler and matt taxi
some of these names are so clever they
almost seem fake
but it doesn't matter that puts us at
74.
uh incredible
absolutely incredible
super chats continue to come in
new abuse awareness public charity
danger aware organization okay
david you should have
richard ogeda on your show he's been on
he has a cause no dem left behind yeah
he's been on before
he's a good guy sedona rose says hi from
arizona i hope nationally progressives
will help us effectively primary cinema
and then beat whichever far-right crazy
runs republican
many people are asking for that
david sur did you see the state trooper
who refused to get vaccinated told the
governor to kiss my ass and is dead of
covet you know i saw it and we will talk
about it monday aj
tristan says you are somehow even more
handsome on profile oh my god tristan
thank you
junie mcgraw says which movement was
worse the tea party or q anon
um
well
the q anon is crazier but they haven't
made inroads to the same degree in the
republican party that's a very good
question actually
that's a really good question
don't know that i have an immediate
answer
i want to say thank you to
a whole bunch of people signing up via
twitch axe thrower jessie kemmy
kimmerzan john weavey the ai overlord
someone whose username is just a bunch
of numbers
hermann akula
evan
beth graham felix pago schulde and
captain smiles
that puts us at 83.
um i saw a question about
what i think of the new
ozark i'm five episodes in and it's
absolutely fantastic
i am
preparing an announcement i i'm not
ready to announce it yet but i'm
considering making an announcement
that ozark is uh the best show since
breaking bad english language show i
would say a lot of a lot of hebrew
language shows and spanish language
shows that are very very good different
i am
preparing a statement we're running it
by our legal team to see if it would be
a problem for me to make this
announcement but i am preparing to take
the position that ozark is the best show
since breaking bad
that's
it is what it is alexander says david i
may have to report you to the fbi for
this completely illegal discount code i
know i know
uh hold on let me see if i got a few
other
see what else i've got here
other videos
no i don't have any other videos from
down there i do have other people to
thank though i do want to say thank you
to desiree dewitt
peter
hope i'm pronouncing that correctly
donald brady
roxanna quorum
catherine dondenville deborah fletcher
allison facette
and caitlin machi all signing up with
the coupon code obama obama putting us
at 91 today
also a huge thank you to wookie jack
combat nurse the forbin project and
vault bar for the twitch prime
subscriptions putting us at 95.
um okay
other super chats coming in
up with a toothache your show and live
chat is a great distraction thanks guys
love and support during divided times
from bristol uk great to see you
and very sorry about the toothache
um
dear god
do you think dems need a charismatic
candidate in 24 yes and i don't know who
that is
i don't think it's aoc i don't even know
if aoc will be old enough
um i i don't know who it is but yes
if alex jones offered you 5 million to
fight him in a boxing match and you had
a year to train would you do it yeah
maybe i mean i think i think what he has
in girth and raw power from his weight
now he now here's the thing it's
completely implausible because we would
be in a different weight class he
probably outweighs me by 2x
is it conceivable that alex jones weighs
300 pounds is that possible
like in no real world would we we'd be
matched up against each other you know
um interesting
interesting
he could be close to 300 yeah
uh yeah it's sort of like
what would you rather um
have uh toenails that uh fall off or uh
eat only avocado the rest of your life
it's like these are unlikely decisions
that i would have to make but
uh
we'll we'll keep an eye out if it
becomes a real question i'll come back
to you guys
vault bar has gifted five subs on twitch
which i really appreciate also thanks to
argenta ryze and darth neo for the prime
subscriptions the website is almost
going to implode under the number of
memberships being dumped in i want to
say thanks to nathan quimby
hold on isn't nathan quimby the name of
the mayor in the simpsons was that
nathan j quimby
anybody remember that
has anybody heard of the simpsons let's
start there oh that was joe quimby oh
okay
nobody's heard of the simpsons all right
thanks to nathan quimby clifton arden
clinton smith and
obama harris
for the website memberships
obama and we will ban
men right
other super chats continuing to come in
we can't stop looking at trump but
attention is monetized feels like i'm in
a dystopian cycle of helping our worst
um
david both my husband chris and i love
your show have you seen the video of
trump getting upset about a whistle at
his rally it's older but still funny no
let's see if i can find that that's i
know when when trump gets upset about
audio feedback it's great
in fact
see if i can set those up
um
where are my audio feedback clips
uh so i've got soundboard
trump
where is feedback
oh no are these gone
donate plasma
it's i have so many clips it's actually
hard to find them
i thought it was towards the back
stupid and stable
oh man i i just can't find him
is it under my classics folder take a
look at the oranges of the investigation
no
no we're looking very strongly at sinks
and showers i can't find i'm sorry guys
um
okay so
trump whistle
no i'm unable to find that one that's
too bad
i've just been notified that luke has
more good clips but he's having trouble
upload loading them
okay i will keep an eye out we have two
two correspondents down in texas doing
interviews here's pillow pillow mingling
with the crowd
um
this is newsmax here
so a lot a lot a lot going on
did you see a collins show that made
marjory taylor green squirmy yeah we
played it at the top of the stream
quirky it's a very good clip very very
good clip alex jones is easily pushing
400 pounds i don't think so david sir
breaking bad is excellent but we got to
show love to the wire greatest show ever
i don't want to lose my entire audience
but i have not seen the wire
i have not seen the lawyer
david pakman is on wiki feet
yes i have been told that i'm aware of
that
uh i don't know how
julia von arb just grabbed a membership
on my website
welcome to melania trump our newest
website member
kelvin hughes is a new member and
jeffrey tiensivu
is a new member i recognize that name
tien cevu
um
there's that there's a particular
country
is tiensavut i don't know why i feel
like tiensvu might be is that a rwandan
last name is that possible
can anybody tell me
hmm
i think i i did just lose i just lost to
antifa
because of my tv show show choices
thanks to pamela pamela aldread and
stephanie bailey for signing up on my
website with the coupon code obama obama
we probably should create a coupon code
related to trump saying ban men right
and we will ban
men
david sir do you see trump proclaiming
himself president for life no no no no
he's not gonna do that
oh they got a big introduction here
[Music]
all right the 45th president of the
united states live from conroe texas
with his
save america rally the second one of
2022 at least but he had a lot of them
last year as well and the crowds have
just grown in size they've gotten larger
and larger
and god bless the united states this
appears to him to be a record crowd in
terms of the rallies it always appears
to be a record i like how she says that
it appears to him to be a record crowd
that's like a genius way of not having
to say it's a record crowd which it
obviously isn't
it appears to trump that it's a record
crowd very technical language being used
there
uh people clamoring for one more
voicemail all right let me see if i can
find something for you guys
here's one
yes
david pickman uh in ottawa there was a
huge coveted
protest against measures of restriction
right yes i saw three things at the
rally in in ottawa i saw
confederate flags
i saw swastikas
and i saw
stars of david
um
those are the three things the most
notable things that stuck out to me
from the uh
from the
trucker rally awful
unpopular complete lasting stock of a
leader justin trudeau
do you guys know if the thing
with the canada rally was it
all canadians or was it american
truckers that for some reason went to
canada for the pro does anybody know
what like what the deal is with that
nobody's sure
okay so a star of david i i i'm
realizing a lot of people don't they
call it a jewish star it's a little bit
cringy to call it a jewish star it's
called the star of david but it's it's
that yellow star that
you know jews during the holocaust were
forced to wear
uh
i'm realizing a lot of people don't know
that that's what it's called
but i appreciate that
thank you to
boba fetta
sterling lana dillinger bookish magpie
flying butterfly and kiss my toe beans
for the twitch prime subscription
putting us at a record setting 119. also
thanks to a bremner for signing up with
the coupon code oh bamna obama very much
appreciate that
um do i have anything else as far as
voicemails go
hmm
so i had um
sort of like a
colleague or friend or something at
my daughter's school
and she was a
therapist
and i just noticed she was like trying
to make trouble
and
uh like my hair is like kind of like
died and then my daughter's just
like this curly big blonde afro
and um interesting like i feel like when
my blonde is like kind of like cringy
it's just stuff that i do because i
don't just make people smile anymore i'm
just hearing and
um
just like she this lady has like their
hair
and what i noticed is that like the
ladies who have like really black dark
hairs like make a huge deal out of
like blonde hair like this
just okay we're done um thanks to small
fuzzy moss who did get me those trump
audio feedback clips
and our incredible oh these people don't
know what the hell they're doing
oh hold on one of them glitched
let me see if i can we we need to fix
the glitch
uh hold on a second
trump and then trump feedback
oh no that's not working
let me pull it back down
feedback
yeah i've really gotta bolster this
thing
okay
here it is
let me recover my ears for one second
okay all right good we're getting really
close here for uh to this to this trump
rally um as you can see they've started
pushing the uh pillow so i have two
options for you guys tonight as far as
coupon codes go okay one option is you
can get pillow stuff from mike pillow
using the coupon code rsbn that's one
option
the second option is you can get a
membership on my website with the coupon
code sad trump
you
you pick okay you pick
uh
okay let me see what else i've got here
we are waiting for some additional clips
from our team on the ground
in uh
in texas
yeah nothing's coming in quite yet
okay we're gonna we're gonna keep an eye
on that thank you to moira takatian
for the website membership anna lena
olsen
and mallory wilson all signing up
putting us at 123. are they playing the
song yet and we love all of the
supporters that you support our partners
no they're not not quite yet
uh yep
we had the over under on trump being
late at 15 minutes
and we are three minutes away from the
15 minute mark so
many of you taking the over although
some took the under on that
and it does look like
it's any minute from from the crowd kind
of getting getting wound up
uh
yeah so i don't i'm not sure
it's going to be very close i think it's
going to be very very close
oh there was no under it's over under
30. oh my god okay i had a different
poll going in my head here's trump stuff
for kids if any of you guys are looking
for some kind of gift
kids guide will help your kids learn all
about the president's greatest
achievements
what's more it's part of a very special
gift bundle that includes a free kids
magazine and free video lesson too to
learn more and order the kids guide to
president trump gift bundle just visit
freetrumpguide.com that's
freetrumpguy.com it'd actually be funny
to order that and then to sit down with
some like smart kids
and see if they fall for any of the
stuff that would actually be interesting
i'd be curious how that would go all
right other super chats
david sir thank you for the funniest and
saddest thing i have or will watch this
weekend that's brian
uh with today's top super chat by a
penny brian beating the previous one by
a penny
jake says do you plan to cover the
bridge that collapsed in pits collapsed
in pittsburgh
i don't know that i have anything to say
about it i'm going to cover the fact
that fox reporter julie banderas was
like this is what happened because biden
paled failed to pass infrastructure and
it was like he did pass infrastructure
but everybody on the panel was nodding
including dave rubin i'm going to cover
that because it's so painfully stupid
the bridge collapse itself i don't know
i mean of course it's more evidence that
the infrastructure money is very much
needed
david i insist you check out the wire
it's amazing and a terribly accurate
description of the american inner city
also i love the curb theme after every
speech please keep it up
yeah we'll keep it going
we'll keep it
going uh thanks to colors atk and razer
ramone as well as chrome boy and enabled
acorn for the twitch prime subscriptions
this crowd is really clamoring for
prompt there seems to be something
happening here some kind of a problem
looks like they're they're maybe
evacuating someone who is not feeling
well there's someone in the back here
for for the next president uh
this is the time the time is now it
looks like they are having to evacuate
someone unfortunately you really do hate
to see that
um
[Music]
unclear if it's a mosh pit incident
or what
but you really you really don't like to
see that david sur just signed up on my
website a user named david sur and his
new member number 128 today
uh i don't know that they sell oh do you
guys want to see something interesting
since we have people on the ground here
they were able to send me the list of
prohibited items here's what you're not
allowed to do you guys want to is this
interesting what you're not allowed to
bring to the rally do you guys want to
hear this because i have the document
oh it's not interesting okay now okay
here's the list of what you can't bring
to the rally you can't bring in any kind
of aerosols or alcoholic beverages you
can't bring appliances including
toasters every time i've been to a rally
i actually bring a gas oven and then i'm
like i should have brought an electric
one there's no gas line here
um you can't bring backpacks bags roller
bags suitcases
you can't bring balloons you can't bring
balls
no banners signs or placards you're not
allowed to bring chairs
you're not allowed to bring coolers you
can't bring drones
e-cigarettes are not allowed explosives
of any kind are not allowed and that
includes fireworks you can't bring
firearms
guns as we might call them you're not
allowed to bring glass thermal and metal
containers you're not allowed laser
lights or laser pointers you're not
allowed mace nor pepper spray they don't
say whether bear spray would be allowed
but i would assume not you can't bring
any kind of noise maker including an air
horn whistle drum or bull horn no
packages
if you were like if you have like an
e-commerce business and you were going
to do pack you set up packages during
the rally you can't do that you can't
bring a pole a stick or a selfie stick
no spray containers of any kind
no structures what does it mean that you
can't bring structures i don't even
understand that like your own bleachers
you can't bring
what does that mean
no tent maybe it means
you can't bring like a trailer a trailer
home
yeah
this is literal communism um you can't
bring supports for any kind of sign or
placard
you can't bring a tripod unipods are not
banned technically you're not allowed to
bring umbrellas and you're not allowed
to bring weapons and by the way if you
really want to see literally 1984
any item at the discretion of security
screeners you are not allowed to bring
if they feel it threatens the security
of the event
uh extremely orwellian guys extremely
orwellian
wow
wow
uh quite quite quite a situation
other super chats coming in
uh pardon me sir do you think there will
be record turnout in this year's
midterms god i hope so what's the best
beer out of massachusetts i don't even
know
um a good beer out of massachusetts is
[Music]
um on
let me see if this one
is from massachusetts
yes there's a great beer called
clementine
by the brewer clown shoes excellent beer
that's a good one
and um
there's another one from newberry port
brewing company
called let me see which one it is
which is the one that's good
the plum island belgian white from
newberry port brewing company very very
solid beers extremely solid
extremely solid
um
okay let's see here i'm i we have a
notification from luke beasley on the
ground in texas david can you please
tease to your audience you will have one
of the most insane interviews ever on
the monday show i need to get better
cellular to edit it together because
it's 10 minutes but a guy was calling
for pence to be executed and a lady
chanted hang mike pence guys i think the
monday show is going to be something
else
i i think the monday show is going to be
wild
of what he was doing which is complete
economic disaster
yeah
truly uh you know and and the world
looks at us liz as we are the beacon of
freedom like whatever happens here
really dictates what's going to happen
the rest of the world so all eyes
okay
um
yeah it's it's monday's show is going to
be absolutely i can't even imagine i
can't even imagine how insane the monday
show is going to be
um
finally signed up on the website david
i'm living in montreal and need to know
how do you feel about montreal bagel
versus new york bagel i was recently
notified about an extremely disturbing
thing about saint viator bagel
in montreal
now
man i don't this it this this could be
so destructive to them i don't even know
that i want to mention it
yeah i'm not even going to mention it
i'm not even going to say it but i am uh
i love montreal bagels
and new york bagels as well no i'm
joking around the saint viator was as as
most uh old-school bagel places are
founded by jewish immigrants but it
since was purchased by
non-jews
saint viator is no longer jewish owned
which for some people makes it less
authentic but they were friends of the
family that started it i'm completely
joking around it's st viator is
fantastic great place to go when you're
in uh when you're in montreal
highly recommend it
i want to say thank you to sandy lamb
cole oh no no i'm not you almost got me
cole almost got me cole i'm just gonna
say cole
james chapman
uh biden is still better than you know
who and loki yogi who just signed up on
my website new members 129
through 133
newsmax still running ads right up until
the last second
also want to say thanks to corbin nasty
questions why te tea
jen pepper
aneer barn ban gucci
one two three four five
twitch prime subscribers very much
appreciate
i can't tell you how thrilled and
flattered i am that we have not only
surpassed
the 1000 viewer mark on twitch
we are
dangerously close to surpassing the 10
000 viewer mark on youtube
i think some people are watching on
facebook too although i i have no idea
how many
anybody know how many people are
watching on facebook
not even sure
uh yeah
wait a second where is
where is my twitch thing hold on a
second
where the hell is this thing
oh there it is oh my god it was just
gone for some reason that was so bizarre
yeah okay so 904 on twitch i i don't
know where that even came from just
everything going wrong technically today
everything going wrong here
other super chats coming in
david any prediction on the opening song
tonight i think it's going to be that
what's that country song that trump
trump always comes out to
what's the name of
it the proud to be an american thing
that was that the name of it okay yeah i
think he'll come out to that
um i really think you'll get a new audio
clip at this rally tonight i think
trump's gonna be fired up he may be
in your opinion what's the best and
worst place to visit in the u.s miami
um
oh you were you you were you're assuming
the best and worst place are two
different places i see
david nothing beats new jersey bagels
that i'm not sure about that that's a
that's a very very aggressive uh
what you've seen in the past
well they're saying anywhere from 50 000
and the last time i was at a rally with
that many people
there guys
there is no way in hell that this is 50
000 people right like there there's no
possible way that that's the number is
there
oh hold on a second
um
it can't put this this cannot be 50 000
people
it's on c-span too they played son of a
preacher oh hold on i would much rather
a clean c-span feed
c-span if we can do c-span c-span's live
right
now let's see
i'm not seeing c-span live
no
um do i have to go to the c-span website
maybe
former president trump texas oh here it
is
okay so that's an additional fee i
always i'll always take an extra feed if
we've got it
i don't know why it's like 240
the quality is toxic guys
[Applause]
[Music]
see if we can clean it up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the quality is horrifying
let's let's keep that as a backup
because the quality is just so bad so so
so bad
um i don't i don't want to subject you
guys to that
um
oh my god luke luke beasley our
correspondent in texas says that when he
pushed back against what hang pence guy
was saying the guy started screaming at
luke but that he wasn't actually scared
but he's gonna have that video for us by
monday i cannot even imagine the stuff
that that he's gonna be sending me it's
insane
uh today's top super chat comes from
giovanni stigma
who says mr pakman sir what was the
website where you buy your ice cream it
looked good and expensive love the show
yes that was graeter's ice cream g-r-a-e
and i recommend the black cherry
very very strong
no structures meaning no gallows
probably right if you plan to bring your
own gallows to the trump rally those
would not be allowed that seems very
very uh likely
i can't imagine they would allow those
thanks to napa skip dog and bone master
jay for the twitch prime subscriptions
uh trump expected to speak for about 90
minutes when he starts
and of course we are 26 minutes late
already
um
i want to say a big thank you and
welcome to cj deck who just signed up on
my website with the coupon code obama
obama also thanks to matthew thielen for
signing up on my website if you're just
joining us
with complete and total humility and
peace and love i invite you to go to my
website and get a membership uh you know
all of the other ways we fund our show
have uh been taken away from us at times
past uh through no control of our own
youtube it's gone to zero uh twitch has
gone to zero facebook we saw it go to
zero two weeks ago so whenever you sign
up on my website you're basically saying
to people like pillow
and zuckerberg and bezos and everybody
else
we're not going to allow you to cut the
to cut the stream
uh because we are signing up directly
and you can use the coupon code obama
for a discount you can also use the
coupon code sad trump if it
if it feels better
it looks like we are going to have to
start banning people
extremely aggressively on twitch very
soon
there's a lot of toxicity speaking of
banning
see any unban requests
yes um
when you get banned on twitch you can
ask to be unbanned
a user on my last stream showed up and
said
god i hate pac-man partisan hack
they were banned
and their unban request is simply clown
uh that's gonna be a perma-ban yeah god
that's just bad faith
we just don't need you here
it's just we just don't we just don't
need you that's it we're fine without
you
can you make a drinking game for us like
if trump says a certain word
um probably not but
you guys want me to pull up trump bingo
i think i do have it
um let me see here
trump bingo
yeah
let me see if i can quickly put this
together
um
i wanted to edit this one though
hold on let's clone it
so now i can edit it there were some
things i wanted to put on here that
aren't on here let me see if we can
quick quickly do this
let me know if trump shows up
uh i had notes so trash
uh
bingo here's trump bingo editions
so we will restore that
trump bingo here it is
okay so mentioning so i don't he doesn't
really mention ratings anymore so i'm
gonna change it to
mentions
crowd size if you guys are okay
um
he hasn't been talking about kamala
so i'm gonna say um
people on stage
visibly bored or leaving i want that
uh anything else that you guys think
should absolutely be added any other
switches we want and then i'll i'll get
everybody the um the link
best stock market
ban man no i don't think he's gonna say
that
uh evident numbers data evidence coming
out soon oh i can't
evidence numbers coming out soon
um
okay biden senile let's get rid of okay
so biden senile
routine
that's good
how about instead of um
what can we go to
how about instead of attacks mike pence
instead of attacks mike pence i had an
idea here
oh yeah uh plays
coy about 2024 i think we want that he's
not here yet
trying to think what else we need
fake news isn't on here
but maybe we'll add it
dancing look he hasn't been dancing
let's let's do fake news yeah that's
good
what about maybe communism socialism
um
what should we replace
get rid of mitch okay
so let's do communism
socialism that's good
oh yeah um
media won't show you the crowd that's a
good one
he hasn't been doing very strongly media
won't show
you the crowd that's a that's a very
good one
um
gas prices let's do gas prices instead
of accordion hands we'll do gas prices
just to make it a different one you know
what i mean um
radical left
yeah let's do
instead of many people have said
let's do radical left and it could
include ists leftists
okay this is gonna be the card all right
so this is the card
let's generate it
and i'm gonna paste it for you
um play online
card is ready
print or download play online here's the
url okay good
beautiful i'm going to paste it here so
anybody who wants to play along can play
along pasted it in twitch
and pasting it
on youtube as well okay good
all right very very good so we'll have
it
um
things are getting a little wacky here
huh they're locally owned locally
produced right here so go to the website
the
simplescrub.com simple jeez
private they have their fancy part all
right so we're standing standing by for
donald trump thanks to those eyes that
mouth
thanks to but it's my hipaa
rainbow nails
brad dick
cachna
slippin shank
for the twitch prime subscriptions
putting us at 148.
um over on my website
i want to say thank you to some really
great people
matt polizzik
just got a subscription sharon gardner
is a new member
john yokochonis is a new member putting
us at 151
also because everything counts today
julie just made a patreon pledge i'm
going to count it
i'm counting it as 152.
also thanks to eurometric what about
someone in the crowd behind him having a
medical crisis from the weather i don't
find that super likely i don't find that
super likely so i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna include that on the bingo card
okay other super chats coming in
do you think trump is the worst u.s
president ever relative to the times
each president lived like for example
slavery was once legal that's a really
tough question to answer i would say um
trump's the worst president of my
lifetime
and i'm 80. so that's that's a lot of
people
uh
thanks to my bag of mangoes for the
twitch sub as well as nick nugget and
meow meow
really appreciate you guys
um
we are uh
standing by any moment for donald trump
should be any second
we are expecting
a number of different lies and different
different things
oh you know what i want to do just to
make it easier for people
i'm going to set up
the bingo board
on a redirect on my website just to make
it easy because having to paste it in
each time it's not
it's just it's just not fair to you guys
i need to make it easier
so i'm going to get that set up if you
give me a moment
this could go quite late into the
evening yeah
without a doubt
let me see where are my settings here
settings and redirects
and bingo
i'm gonna edit
save
and clear okay
here is trump i believe if you can go to
davidpakman.com
bingo you will find the bingo board yeah
uh what about 35 minutes
late that's not too bad for him
a lot of handshaking has to do backstage
and we will thanks to deeper shades of
house for gifting five subs as well as
our daily hands out his save america
hats there um i i hope that he talks a
lot about bringing folks together
because i think uh thanks to aaron
mulholland
for the website membership aaron just
signed up on my website with the coupon
code obama obama
also want to make sure
that everybody knows
all
genders and sexes are welcome here no
matter what donald trump says and we
will ban men
exactly that is not something you're
gonna hear
on this show
not on this show guys
uh
we should almost do another over under
like will it be more than five minutes
until trump even starts speaking tonight
to share their views uncensored on this
social media app and maybe we'd be able
to hear from the president in a short
number of characters on social media
so they actually have a bigger blacks
for trump presence on the stage today
than we've maybe ever seen before to be
perfectly frank
i don't know that we've ever seen such a
presence thanks to steven france for
signing up on my website i appreciate
that stephen yes the super chats are
going to continue
uh throughout
and if you want to play bingo
davidpakman.combingo
how long will it take to get a
soundboard quote from from tonight's
speech over or under at 15 minutes
that's a that's a really good question
uh and of course here is the bingo board
and uh
oh wait a second is this oh no
it seems like this is the wrong link oh
my god
no we oh man
oh god i shared my own one hold on a
second
oh no
what a disaster
i think i messed that up guys i think
we're all playing on the same card
man i might have really messed that up
okay here we go sorry do that they don't
want to show the kind of crowds we get
oh we already got that because our
country is angry and our country wants
to be respected again
hello texas it's great to be back
in this wonderful beautiful
state with thousands of proud american
patriots who believe in family and
freedom god and country and by the way
oil and guns oh my god that eye is
swollen almost completely shut
unlike the democrats
nine months from now the people of this
state are going to send a thundering
message
to the radical left democrats in
washington d.c
you're going to tell them don't mess
with texas because texas is
never ever
turning blue
[Music]
quite a prediction
that is
unless they rigged the election like
they've been doing in numerous
other
states and governor the governor's here
your great governor's here don't let
them do it governor
we had a great
big victory in the state of texas just
be careful with these people they're
treacherous we're here tonight for a
simple reason
because together
we have to save america there's never
been a time like this there's never been
a time that's the new valley what joe
biden and the pelosi schumer congress
have done to our country in just one
year is a travesty
of the highest order
inflation is skyrocketing gas prices are
soaring
supply chains are crumbling can you
believe what's happening you can't get
anything the shelves are empty
i did a book they can't publish it
anymore they can't get the paper the
glue the ink
go out and buy it you'll like it
murders are surging illegal this is not
exactly a reading crowd millions and
millions
china is threatening taiwan iran is on
the cusp of a nuclear bomb russia may
take over ukraine
do you hear that crowd back there can
you believe it
i was just informed by a wonderful local
politician this is the biggest crowd of
its kind in the history of texas
look at it
and the fake news will say a smattering
of people showed up hold on the lions
are going back 30 miles long the cars
are still coming so i want to thank
everybody this is great it's incredible
[Music]
and we're gonna have a good time tonight
aren't we huh
somebody said jesus where would you
rather be
on a saturday night than a trump rally
in texas
see now biden would say where
there's biden senile hold on he said
he'd say
where would you rather be on a thursday
night
in the state of oklahoma no this is
texas you can say this is texas
well we love you too
we love you too
and we all got screwed together but you
know what guys closed captioning is on
it's just not coming through
north korea is testing at a level
like never before the way they
withdrew from afghanistan was
catastrophic and
image changing for the united states of
america image changing
that did so much to hurt our country
that was a moment that was so
embarrassing and so horrible
and joe biden's weakness and
incompetence is creating a very real
risk
of world war three look at what's going
on this would have never happened with
us never even it was never even a
thought would have never happened
if you care about your future your
family and your country then you have no
choice this november you have to throw
these raving lunatics the hell out of
power and elect
strong smart tough republicans who
restore
your borders protect your safety defend
your jobs and
put america first
with biden and the radical left it's
always america last and that's what they
do you look at these horrible
deals they make
throughout the world it's always america
last
everyone in washington is obsessing over
how to protect
ukraine's border but the most it is a
good question i don't know why trump's
blurry and the background is in focus
it's very strange
it's america's border and we do nothing
about it but let
people come in and we have no idea who
they are the first duty
of the american president is to defend
the american border
before our leaders talk about invasion
it almost looks like a green screen they
need to stop the invasion of this
country is being invaded
it's being invaded by people that should
not be allowed that's dehumanizing
language of course the strongest border
that we've ever had just one year ago
and before joe biden send any troops to
defend a border in eastern europe he
should be sending troops to defend our
border right here in texas
when i left office we handed so many
incredible things to the new
administration but one of the best was
that
great secure border
and it wasn't even close there's never
been a border like that you saw it
people tell me they said it was like we
were living in a different world is
trump's right eye at all open stop not
only the people coming in that we didn't
want in most cases or certainly in many
cases but the drugs now are surging we
had it down to the lowest level in
decades
yet under biden over 5 million people
trespassed illegally across our border
last year alone think of it 5
million people and we have no idea who
the hell they are
or where they came from but you'll be
paying a price
for years to come
this was not a let's see what this is
looking like this is even blurrier guys
let me refresh once and see but it's
it's extraordinarily blurry we
trespassed illegally across our border
it's horrifying i can't do that in good
faith to you guys or fourth world
countries they wouldn't allow this to
happen
normally a nation has to lose a war to a
foreign power in order to lose its
border and yet our border has been
surrendered look we have surrendered our
border
right it's been surrendered by our own
president and the democrats just like
biden surrendered at least he's calling
him our president the entire planet
is intruding across it as though america
had been defeated on the field of battle
there's no other excuse for it and even
during the debates nobody said that this
was going to happen nobody said we were
going to have totally open borders and
if they said it we wouldn't have
believed him no nobody would have
believed that
biden's complete
abdication of duty is getting untold
numbers of
innocent americans killed
when biden's watched last year border
patrol saw a 350 percent increase
in criminal aliens breaking across our
border including
1
900 now remember when he says criminal
aliens he doesn't actually mean people
who committed crimes here they they just
they they call them criminal aliens once
they're here undocumented and is this an
important distinction state of new york
three savage illegal alien ms-13 gang
member killers
were charged last year with beating a 31
year old mother
with a baseball bat
hacking her to pieces with a machete and
stuffing her body
into this remember that our bingo card
has an item which is that the people
behind trump look visibly bored
you guys let me know when you think that
starts happening
at a gas station in suburban kentucky
shot her 16 year old son who was in the
car
and went on a two-week long crime spree
a brutal
carjackings and what's happening now
robbery you're probably hurting many
people right now in hospitals all over
that
great state
in beverly hills california the crime is
so bad that rich people leave their car
trunks open
so the vandals and thieves won't destroy
their cars
when robbing them think of that that's
beverly hills a lot of money in beverly
hills right they're not so happy you
know people have asked me and they said
would you do it i said i'll do it i have
to find it but i'm going to do it is it
going to do this nice to have a memory
where you don't really have to oh read
it but let's read it anyway
let's read it anyway
they wanted to hear the snake i haven't
done that does anybody know what that is
it's horrific and this says you know has
to do with immigration
do you want me to do it
and we will bend so this has to do
really with immigration
and
it's a very serious problem for our
country we have many serious problems
we're in the losing end of every if if
you're new to these rallies this is one
of the most xenophobic dog whistles the
crowd gets worked up into a veritable
lather from this uh thing along the lake
a tender hearted woman saw a poor
half frozen snake
his pretty colored skin had been all
frosted with the dew
poor thing it's particularly funny
because this is not exactly a poetry
crowd you
take me in oh tender woman take me in
for heaven's sake
take me in oh tender woman sighed the
vicious snake
she wrapped him up all cozy in a
comforter of silk and laid him by her
fireside
with some honey
and some milk
milk she heard home from work that night
and soon as she arrived
she found that pretty snake she'd taken
in
had been fully revived
take me no tender woman take me in for
heaven's sake take me in this guy right
here just loves this [ __ ] look at this
guy
she clutched him to her bosom
you're so beautiful she cried
but if i didn't bring you in by now
you truly
would have died
she stroked his pretty skin again and
kissed and held him tight
but instead of saying
thank you ma'am
the snake gave her a vicious bite
take me you know tender woman take me in
for heaven's sake
take me in oh tender woman
side the vicious snake
i saved you cried the woman
and you've bitten me but why
you know your bite is poisonous
and now i'm going to die
countries are really messed up guys
silly woman
said the reptile with a grin
you knew damn well i was a snake
before you took me in
and that's
what's happening
to the united states
of america
with immigration
i think it's pretty accurate do you
agree i think it's pretty accurate crowd
doesn't doesn't get it's pretty accurate
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
accurate
[Music]
did mussolini write that
[Applause]
this is actually pretty scary like this
this is a horrifying horrifying moment
in uh american history hopefully this is
all
catalogued in history books because this
is this is very bad republicans retake
congress one of the first things they
should do
is pass a bill massively increasing the
number of ice officers to ensure that
every single illegal alien joe biden
led into our country
illegally as safely and quickly sent
back home have to do it we're not going
to have a country
every day biden's incompetence is
putting america at risk as everyone
knows what putin and russia are doing
with you you guys noticing this is the
2016 campaign
just replacing the word obama with the
word biden that's the only difference
here
never did
they would not have dreamed of it and
they would not have
dared to do it and i had a good
relationship but remember i'm the one
that broke up his pipeline deal he
wasn't happy about that he said you're
killing me with a pipeline nobody else
brought a pipeline nobody ever heard
about nordstream 2.
in the words of the great historian and
he is indeed a great historian and
philosopher
victor david hanson you know victor
davis hanson
to me is one of the great people around
victor this crowd knows historians
that's absolutely true putin didn't move
and he's talking about over
many years
was in this four-year period when trump
did things like take out salamani kill
al-baghdadi completely destroy
isis
and be smart with north korea
and he said at russia during this
during this four-year period russia
didn't move we had a good relationship
but he understood we both understood he
didn't move there was nothing like
having 250 000 soldiers on the border of
a country
when my watch america was respected
again
may be respected like never before
[Applause]
and i was proud to be the first
president in decades who did not get the
united states into any new wars i took
us out of endless and ridiculous wars he
didn't take us out of endless and
ridiculous wars
he didn't get us into a new war but he
certainly
did military hostilities it's sort of a
meaningless talking point because they
didn't want to mess with us totally
rebuilt the military nobody wanted to
mess of course we gave 85 billion of it
to the taliban
not even it's not even believable
we truly had peace through strength as
ronald reagan would say we demanded that
our nato allies pay their fair share and
i made clear that if europe cared
about its borders they would have to pay
they would have to pay because we were
paying for nato
and by the way they screwed us on trade
all the time you know they were almost
as bad as china but nobody says it
because it's europe how nice it's such a
great place did we hit china a lot of us
came from europe at one point
whether it's us our parents our
grandparents but they were very good at
taking advantage of the united states
americans were not going to be played
for suckers
anymore under the trump administration
it was very clear and they understood
that
a big part of the reason we are now
witnessing this dangerous situation in
ukraine
is that as soon as biden came in other
countries got the message that it was
back to the old days of taking advantage
of the united states that they didn't
have to pay their bills people are
wanting this stream instead but it's a
risky stream
didn't have to pay their bills do their
jobs or risk
their lives let the dumb americans do it
for us
the incompetence of our leaders could be
scarcely believed
it's a disaster and a disgrace what's
happened to our country in the last 10
months a disaster a disgrace
nobody can believe it
[Music]
remember there's a reason
that joe biden can't walk into a sports
stadium anywhere in america
without being loudly mocked
and ridiculed
yeah i don't know why the closed
captioning's on it's not coming up it's
weird
joe biden chuck schumer crazy nancy
pelosi and she's crazy as a bedbug that
one
nuts
he made a phone call to ukraine to
congratulate the man who just became
president we have to impeach him can you
imagine and
hunter biden's taking 83 000 a month and
gets 3 million dollars sign up fee
even though he knew nothing about oil
you have to go to texas grab anybody in
the audience but it wasn't hunter no but
can you imagine crazy nancy let's
impeach the president of the united
states for congratulating the president
of ukraine and that call that was made
yesterday with biden
if that was even half what they said
that was not a good call in fact the
president of ukraine was saying to him
supposedly calm down just calm down
i think we're okay just calm down
can you please
this is incredible what
but they're sinister faces of
corruption
lawless
political establishments like this
should not be allowed to continue they
send young americans to fight and die
for the borders of distant foreign
nations while they throw our borders
open to a legal foreign invasion we
fight for other borders but we don't
fight for our own
they torture your children with masks in
school while they host parties packed
with
unmasked donors in new york
san francisco and washington d.c
they restrict your freedom
and lock you in your home while they
abolish cash bail and release thousands
of danger
really dangerous murderers
dangerous
trump actually sounds as bored as the
crowd tonight it's interesting
they drive up the price of your energy
for your family while they are shuttled
around in limos and airplanes
on american taxpayer
dollars
they censor
cancel and
persecute ordinary citizens for speaking
the truth
while they drown your endless torment of
i mean what they do
they have an endless
list of propaganda and propaganda
methods that nobody would believe
including hoaxes
and demented lies we had all of the
hooks as the american people are sick of
this entire rotten and wretched
political class think about it other
countries they have a country we have a
country all they do is try and
destroy you thank you very much
no it's true it's a perfect that was
much better than i was going to come up
thank you whoever the hell you are put
your hand up
nice
thank you
thank you for the hand
usually that's left for joe biden i'm a
little embarrassed i just liked it much
better than
what i was going to say
they're fed up with politicians who rig
and steal our elections and our wealth
squander our strength and spill our
blood all over the world
and in many cases for absolutely no
reason by countries and for countries
that don't even want us there and don't
even like us and certainly don't respect
us
in
2022
we are going to start by ending nancy
pelosi's political career once and for
all
who's going to beat her in her district
and then we're going to kick the biden
crime family out of the white house in
2024
a really great new book by
peter schweitzer which is a terrific
book actually a sad book very sad
because of what it says and represents
just reported that the biden family has
collected over 31 million dollars from
entities linked
to the chinese communist party 31
million dollars
that's in addition to the 83 000 a month
from the ukrainian energy company which
a lot of people said was very corrupt
the millions from the mayor of moscow's
wife millions three and a half million
dollars what was that for i really don't
know
remember the laptop from hell when they
found it no what did they say
the russians did it oda russia said it
remember that that turned out to be like
everything else totally false can you
imagine
when he realized that his laptop from
hell was missing
and that they found it
but the fake news didn't even when a
great book on that was done the fake
news didn't even want to talk about it
and all the rest of the biden's graph
that was censored by the
media and the big tech giants during the
campaign and the reason they did that
is because they knew that it represented
maybe 15 points and maybe more of
downfall in other words even with all of
their cheating all of the horrible
things they did during the election even
with that they would lose the election
it represented a 15 point fall
so the media got together and outside of
the new york post who do we think is the
most bored looking person on stage i'm
going to take a really close look now
radical democrats spent years
investigating fake scandals the mueller
hoax impeachment hoax number one
impeachment hoax number two the unselect
committee on january 6. how about that
committee
this guy looks very bored
this kid has seemed almost comatose the
entire rally
criminal harassment in new york and
atlanta of a person known as donald
trump have you ever heard of him
and biden has the real scandals and rest
assured when republicans retake congress
the biden corruption will be
investigated and exposed
but we no longer have a free and fair
press if we did all of this would end it
wouldn't be there
it's actually just the opposite as an
example
one american news do we like it
oh it's a very popular carrier of
our voice your voice my voice
everybody's voices
and unexpectedly last week they
announced that they're going to be
shutting down this is a t and t
shutting down
one american news
[Applause]
they're actually just not going to be
carrying it directv which is owned by
time warner
is just i mean think of it
think of it cnn
how bad by the way tell me
how bad and how fake is cnn
[Applause]
so one american news which is wonderful
they're going to shut it down
and if they shut down oen you should
boycott a t and direct tv
but sir isn't that cancel culture they
shut it down people love it people love
it and it's got a big audience it's
purely political
and if you look at the chairman of the
board and if you look at the other
people you'll understand what's going on
and while you're at it boycott comcast
and xfinity while you're at it
i call it con c-o-n con is he aware that
most people have one cable option so
basically boycotting these companies
means you just have no tv country the
millions of dollars the bidens took from
china
also explains why
joe has refused to hold the communist
party accountable for unleashing
the virus on us and the rest of the
world biden's letting china be rewarded
almost like
boycott boeing like well
i guess i'm not going to a lot of places
mandates and attacks on our freedoms and
by the way
we have a couple of people here that are
very brave
the herrings mr herring i heard he was
here i just heard that pickled robert
herring charles herring where are you
charles herrick
they are the ones and they're american
patriots
they own
where are you
i want to thank you on behalf
87 of the people here
they own
oan
one american news
and they have done such a job at great
personal
[Music]
expense i want to thank you charles and
robert thank you very much
great personal expense
and you've done a fantastic job and
let's see what happens remember
direct tv
boycott it if they terminate this
incredible group of people because they
really get the word out and they get the
truth out and you can't be terminating
they have enough problems with this
country without terminating
the truth
it's time for the american people to
declare independence from every last
coven
mandate
we have to tell this
band of hypocrites tyrants and racists
that we're done with having them control
our lives mess with our children and
close our businesses we're moving on
from covent
whether they like it or not we're moving
on
is anybody aware of any draconian
coveted restrictions right now cause
like i i've just got been traveling all
over the country in the last six weeks
everything's open
and
sometimes you see people wearing masks
more of us
then there are of them
it's true the canadian truckers you've
been reading about it
who are resisting
bravely these lawless mandates are doing
more to defend american freedom
than our own leaders by far and we want
those great canadian truckers to know
that we are with them all the way they
are they've really shown
something like buffoons
time to move on next year a republican
congress should pass a bill rehiring
every single member of the military who
is cruelly and wrongfully
terminated by joe biden
and his
ridiculous covet mandate and forced the
pentagon to give these patriots an
apology and full back pay
that's not going to happen
we're thrilled to be joined tonight by
many great republican leaders
and i want to introduce some of the
places loaded we are loaded 85 000
people they want to be here they're
politicians now they're saying it's 85 i
thought it was it just went from 50 000
people to 85 000 people long time ago
very early
he got me to spend so much money on
texas he wants to build a dam so we
don't have any more floods during
the storms
i said how much would that cost
approximately 10 billion oh that sounds
reasonable governor
but he's a great governor he loves the
state has my complete and total
endorsement greg abbott governor greg
abbott
we will ban
men
a man
where is greg
thank you greg thank you thank you
governor
looking good governor wait he waved to
someone to his left first and seemed
convinced that that was greg abbott
turns out greg abbott's over to his
right right and he's a wonderful person
and his son has done a fantastic job as
u.s attorney
dan patrick dan patrick lieutenant
governor you might remember dan patrick
as the guy who earlier in the pandemic
said
grandma would sacrifice herself to save
the stock market i think this one is
great could you give them an endorsement
i said absolutely dad whatever you want
then he's gotten a hell of a lot of
endorsements but you've done a great job
and they've been great people you
recommend i will say
an attorney general who has really led
the way
somebody who has been brave and strong
[Applause]
ken paxton can
brave and strong
it's really a who's who of deplorables
in texas they all have my complete and
total endorsement and so do many of the
others monday
is the last day to register to vote in
the primary on march 1st
so you got to get out there texas and
vote you're going to have some great
people going against some democrats and
they're going to win a man who was a
fantastic secretary of energy and a an
incredible governor
mister and governor and secretary rick
perry where's rick oh
rick
thank you rick thank you man
thank you rick
now we have a lot of congressmen
warriors with us
so congressman and representatives just
great people we'll start brian babin
where's brian brian thank you brian
john carter
thank you john thank you
michael cloud he just went up we gave an
endorsement he went like a rocket ship
right up
pat fallon pat thank you very much
a wonderful guy served a long time's
done a great job kevin what's the most
boring part of the rally is it when
trump names people in the crowd or when
he plays a video for the crowd my doctor
he knows everything about
i don't know if he was a better doctor
admiral or
congressman i don't know it could be
congressman actually you they love you
they love ronnie jackson right
they were getting a little nasty they
didn't like that we were doing so well
so they said maybe this guy's not with
it and i said ronnie can i take some
kind of a test is there something like
you can sir but it's very hard
i said what's hard well the first
questions are easy but then it gets
harder and harder when you get to
question number 30 it's pretty hard sir
i said well would anyone know if i did
badly right
i said well you know it is walter reed a
lot of people see what's happening i
better do well
he said what do you think i said i don't
know i did pretty well in my life let's
take it
and i took this cognitive test
and as ronnie said i got every single
question right he said he's still
bragging about the dementia test guys
from that point on they didn't talk they
found other things then they said he
wants to be a dictator he wants to be
they went on to other things but i think
biden should do the same thing ronnie
would you administer the test please it
would solve so many problems i have a
feeling he won't be doing it anytime
soon do you agree but seriously ronnie
jackson has done a great job no matter
where he's been they love him in texas
and i mean listen we're all having a
grand old time but this is this is very
very scary extraordinarily scary as i've
ever said if he did he actually said
if he didn't eat junk food he'd live to
200 years old right and he was kidding a
little but he got himself into trouble
with that one we love ronnie thank you
very much ronnie
another man very brave got shot actually
got shot and he handled it incredibly
well during that very horrible period
that everybody
knows about it roger williams roger
where are you roger thank you roger very
weird way
this is a great guy who got shot he got
shot commissioner sid miller sid
you know i watched it on television the
first race and the second they said sir
you know it's a very close race to
telling him some interview radical left
probably said he said texas is going to
be very close he said i don't know where
you come from son but texas is not going
to be very close trump is going to win
it in his landslide and that's what
happened twice
so we appreciate it thank you sid
he said i don't know what the hell
you're talking about son you don't know
too much we have some great people from
out of state
missouri attorney general eric schmidt
eric
thank you eric great job eric great
arkansas attorney general wonderful
woman wonderful friend leslie rutledge
is this better or worse than when during
the 2016 campaign he would just take out
a piece of paper and read polling
numbers it's actually tough to say a
place called new york
we should
by the way i think this is worse louie
gohmert in the audience where the hell
is william
louis gohmert
i got all these people
i don't even know they're coming louie
gomer what a wonderful guy congressman
louie gohmert this is a man who's been a
friend of mine from day one thank you
louis for being i just saw you sitting
there he's very distinctive with that
beautiful face
all right thank you louis that's exactly
and i see another one
gomer is absolutely horrifying his
physical appearance and he sells
everything
it's pillow
mike lindell
the fact that the crowd loves lindell is
also really scary
[Music]
i think he's the single greatest
purchaser of advertising i've ever seen
i said mike
i don't care how many pillows you sell
and now you're selling slippers and
sheets you're selling everything i said
i don't care you can't afford that much
advertising i think you know what he
does he waits till the show is just
ready to go on
any empty slot he says i'll give you two
hundred dollars for it to fox
i'll give you 200 and they'll say no we
want three he said nope i'll go 201.
you're the greatest buyer of ads i've
ever seen
and a lot of other good things too by
the way so mike lindell everybody very
good guy
whoa
that's pretty good
there's like two sides to this it's
extremely scary that people find this
something to go to
it's also extremely sad in a way that
people find these characters interesting
like these are some of the least
interesting people to hear from period
attorney general jason roundsburg
jason thank you for being here
appreciate it they like you in texas
they like all of you in texas
state senator dawn buckingham
[Applause]
good luck good luck you're gonna have a
good a good solid victory state
representative steve toth steve
he's a big guy for stopping the election
fraud
judge mark
judge
[Music]
thank you mark
a lot of power that guy a lot of power
gonzalez bear
connie cassier
connie kissier thank you thanks connie
good luck in your race
and texas gio peach here he's done a
fantastic job matt rinaldi thank you
matt
thanks thank you matt great job you've
done
and a very special thanks to a
longest serving gop chair longest
serving in history i guess
92 year old i watched him i talked to
him backstage he's still a dynamo doctor
wally wilkerson wally thank you
thanks wally
he's still a dynamo
[Applause]
we're also joined by
one of the greatest pictures
easily one of the greatest pitches in
baseball
history
roger clemens with his incredible wife
oh god that is that
look at him i'm glad clemens didn't get
into the hall of fame a couple days ago
man that is vile thank you fairly they
were big fans that guy was boy was he
good man
nobody messed with him he used to throw
at the head by the way in general when
trump lists names it can get bad do you
guys remember this incident
people cheer on some of the world's
greatest cricket players
from such in tendo
[Music]
yeah it's what we call high risk
teleprompter high-risk teleprompter sons
are all great your family just great
athletes and one son i understand made
the roster of the detroit tigers right
that's great
they'll have to change the name of the
detroit tigers because they don't want
to it's unfair
to use the word tiger you know they're
changing the name of
the cleveland indians can you believe
that one
can you believe that i didn't realize
that clemens was such a complete idiot
tiger is probably at play also
everything's at play if you let these
people get away with it they'll destroy
your whole country okay it's crazy
i also want to say a brief word about
the
atrocities this week in the houston area
where three brave police officers were
brutally shot
in the line of duty on thursday
a harris county officer was murdered by
an illegal alien in a traffic stop on
sunday illegal alien where did he come
from
and another officer was also horribly
killed and i just want to pay
my respects the houston police and law
enforcement has treated us with such
incredible dignity and respect and
they're incredible people and i want to
thank them and if they want to stand up
but the houston
police have been incredible are there
any there do we know everybody in texas
is incredible but our heart breaks for
those courageous officers that we've
just lost
we send our prayers we send our
everlasting love to their families we
ask god to
help our wounded heroes make a swift and
full recovery together we will always
back our great men and women in blue
won't we huh
oh wait
over the past 12 months we have seen the
starkest contrast between two successive
presidents in the history of our country
let's simply compare the records in one
year joe biden's socialist spending bins
sparked the worst inflation in 40 years
and soon to be probably 92 years from
what they're predicting
the grocery stores are running out of
food
the congressional budget office slashed
its long-term growth forecast way way
back
30 percent and it's going to be much
higher than that
more americans died of covet on biden's
watch than in all of 2020
at least 16 democrat-run cities saw
record high numbers of murders and
drug abuse and every other form of crime
suburbs are seeing
surging carjackings and smash and grab
we never heard of that term before they
just run into department stores and
smash the hell out of it and grab it
and they just get out for nothing
there's no
recrimination biden is abolished the
southern border canceled the keystone xl
pipeline
re-entered the unfair
and very expensive unfairly very
expensive
horrible paris climate accord rip-off
it's a rip-off of our country
caused gas prices to skyrocket by more
than 100 in a year
and then begged opec
for mercy please please send us more
energy
he's emboldened iran betrayed israel and
presided over the catastrophe in
afghanistan by contrast and that's just
a few i didn't want to bore you with
going on i could go on for 10 more
minutes
by contrast we had perhaps the most
successful four years of any president
in american history
before the pandemic we built the
greatest economy in the history of the
world we created over 7 million new jobs
and achieved the lowest unemployment
rates for african americans hispanic
americans and asian americans ever
recorded and you could add women you
could add high school diplomas non-high
school diplomas diplomas from mit
harvard yale the wharton school of
finance you could add them all everybody
was doing better than ever before
we lifted 7 million people off food
stamps and 10 million people off welfare
we accomplished the largest poverty
reduction in more than 50 years in the
united states and the lowest
african-american and hispanic american
poverty rates also in recorded history
after the pandemic hit
and that horrible horrible plague came
in from china we saved the us economy
and launched the fastest recovery on
record
it's never seen anything like it we
handed over something that was
incredible we withdrew from the
trans-pacific partnership replaced nafta
with the usmca with texas being one of
the biggest beneficiaries
it's such a good deal that mexico and
canada you saw that mexico and canada
want to get out of it
they'd like to get out of it no thanks
because for years years years they
ripped us off with nafta we should i
guess start thinking maybe about an over
under
on whether he'll go 90 minutes under 90
minutes or over 90 minutes let me figure
out exactly when when that would put us
of dollars in taxes and in tariffs
that's never happened before to china
and they want to now ease it up on china
can you believe it we unleashed american
energy and with the help of the proud
texas energy workers we achieved america
so we're right at about 45 so so 90
minutes would put us at basically 10 0 8
p.m eastern
500 miles of border wall
and would have had it all complete in
three weeks except they decided to stop
building and reach
you take a look reached numbers like
you've never seen before on illegal
border crossings they were down by 91
percent
and would have gone even lower than that
we would have had it almost completely
stopped people can come into our country
but they have to love our country and
they have to come in legally it's very
simple
we slashed violent crime for three
straight years and deployed federal law
enforcement to democrat-run cities to
put dangerous offenders behind bars and
we would have gone all the way but we
wanted to let them see if they can
handle it first but they turned out that
they can't they cannot handle it
democrat-run cities are a disaster in
the united states
we appoint you remember that cities in
general tend to be run by democrats both
cities with high crime cities with low
crime
democrats just prefer to live in cities
republicans prefer to live rurally on
average
we fully rebuilt the united states
military and created the first new
branch of the u.s armed forces in more
than 75 years
space force there they are there they
are
recruit that's this is something that
people can't even believe because you've
heard this for years they couldn't do
anything we crushed
the isis territorial caliphate 100
[Applause]
we knocked out 100
remember remember i had it at 95 i said
all right let's go home they all said he
didn't do a hundred so we stayed a
little longer we did a hundred they
couldn't do it
nobody bush didn't do it
obama didn't do it obama barack hussein
obama how's he doing
how's he doing
how is he doing we withdrew from the
disastrous iran nuclear deal and
disaster now they want to go back into
it it's a path for them to have nuclear
weapons it's horrible
recognize jerusalem as the capital of
israel
recognized israeli sovereignty over the
golan heights
struck historic peace deals in the
middle east the abrahamic courts
and brought back our troops we brought
them back home where they should be and
yet another biden disaster this week it
was reported that the administration is
planning to swamp our communities with
even more
unvetted unscreenable refugees from
afghanistan thank you very much
they'll be in a house near you you won't
even know it
since biden's surrender he has already
brought in thousands and thousands of
totally unvetted
afghan nationals only a tiny percentage
of whom ever helped the united states
three percent three percent deserve to
be here they came out on the plains
and there's never been a site
where this is pretty serious red meat
dog whistling planes when they were 2
000 feet in the air can you believe that
what was worse that looks like someone
may be having a medical event here some
uh someone's being helped out i guess
a three-year-old child under my or back
i don't even know instituted historic
reforms
cutting refugee admissions by 85 percent
and insisting that no refugee
resettlement could take place without
the consent of cities and states
with the republican congress we must
pass and we will pass that critical
national security protection into law
it will be done trump's acting like he's
the president it's it's funny and scary
because a lot of these people are also
acting like he's the president to solve
one of the most important issues of all
ensuring free
fair and honest elections
by the way the number of people that
we've been quietly banning on twitch and
youtube tonight it's it's unbelievable
[Music]
and everyone knows it
you know who knows it more than anyone
else the democrats just yesterday we had
a giant victory in the great state of
pennsylvania a statewide court ruled
that the practice of no excuse mail-in
ballots put in place by democrats right
before the stolen election is illegal
and flagrantly unconstitutional
and therefore i assume we won the state
i assume understand that all of this is
a lie then none of these things are true
they're really going strong on the fraud
where a judge ruled that drop boxes
you know they call them the lock boxes
right i call them the unlock boxes
that they were illegal they were illegal
tens of thousands of votes he ruled that
they were illegal
we have a woman with us today catherine
engelbrecht
who heads through the vote
which has uncovered massive illegal
ballot harvesting and other people are
starting to really are people leaving i
don't even understand what's going on
here
they call them ballot murals these are
people they call it yeah okay yep save
america red hat guy here followed by a
line of children they're headed out i
guess
they stuffed the ballot boxes
in georgia and other states
and i just want to thank where is
catherine is she arrived
what a job she's done thank you
thank you catherine
and they have it on tape now all they
have to do is release the tape they
don't want to release the tape they
don't want to release the tape but it's
in tape and it's on tape in more than
just one there is nothing being said
here that's true there's no tapes
there's no ballot stuffing there's no
massive dumps of votes there's none
there's none of it actually was a fraud
they don't like it
let's see what happens ever since word
got out
they have been flooded with tips and if
you have any information about ballot
harvesting in your state
guys now in almost february of 2022
please help us get the data we need to
flip arizona from 2020. a lot of people
in this audience saw plenty
the radical democrats
are corrupt beyond belief
they are viciously and
unconstitutionally using the federal
local and state governments to
prosecuted silence
politicians
like me although i never consider myself
to be a politician
but that's what they're doing as an
example for years they've been going
after my company
many years using every trick in the book
in an attempt to literally if they can
put me in jail they want to put me in
jail
this has been going on since i came down
the
escalator with our great future first
lady who ever i believe that's the day
he said that mexico is not sending its
bests it's it's best but not all of them
are rapists absolutely
missing in action for this stuff it's
going on all over the country as an
example
local prosecutors in new york and other
locations who horribly campaigned for
office on we're going to get trump this
is how they campaign we're going to get
trump they know nothing about me we're
going to get him
then got elected and are working
overtime to fulfill their came campaign
promises they've subpoenaed more than
nine million
pages big company of documents and
virtually every deal i've ever done
hoping to find a mistake
an error misspelled words a comma out of
place it's not an era
to
um
tell banks that the buildings are worth
one thing and then to tell tax
authorities that they're worth another
thing
that that's not that's not an error
very very well
as an example the attorney general of
new york has hundreds of venomous quotes
about me during actually poisonous not
venomous the district attorney of
manhattan where crime death and killings
are rampant like never before has
happily stated that i have sued trump
more than any other person alive over
100 times
and then he gets elected to take
over
the former attorney general's job and
he's been after my family for years but
unable to find anything they haven't
been able to find anything
other than a fringe benefits case
and accountants will tell you fringe
benefit cases are not criminal cases
there's never been that they know of a
fringe benefits case
there's never been a witch hunt or a
fishing expedition like this there's
never been anything like it and despite
all of this look at the job we did this
has been going on for years
and this is murderers and drug dealers
roam the sidewalks of new york they have
a big portion of their
of their staff working on donald trump
how do we get this guy
this has been does trump dr know how to
drive a car do we do we know or is he
one of those guys who's just like he
doesn't ever drive because he doesn't
ever have to and he doesn't even know
how all democrats and we're leading by a
lot
by the way
[Applause]
if i ever wave sayonara texas i'm gonna
go take it easy everything would stop
and have a very wonderful life but we
don't want to do that because we have to
save a country our country is dying
our country is dying
[Applause]
but that's really what they want it
really is processing we did get this
mexico
mexico and horrible people they're
racist and they're very sick they're
mentally sick
they're going after me
without any protection of my rights by
the supreme court or most other courts
in reality
they're not after me they're after you
and i just happen to be the person
that's in the way that's what they're
after it's been going on for years
and you want to hear one just to get off
the subject but you want to hear what i
just said i got to put this down because
it's so crazy
so just listen to this to top it all off
about how crooked
the da's office in new york is they
couldn't get anything on me after years
so hillary clinton's law firm
[Music]
paul weiss rifkind wharton in garrison a
big and
powerfully connected democrat firm in
new york
run by listen to this one chuck
schumer's brother
sent one of their biggest partners mark
pomerantz partner of the firm
who took a leave of absence from the law
firm and two of their best younger
lawyers to the district attorney's
office to work there full-time for free
how the hell do you like that i got
hillary clinton's law firm trying to
prosecute me
this is the most corrupt
system
so i've got the firm
mexico
and we will
[Applause]
you know what all these attorney
generals maybe you guys can get involved
a little bit because
they're making you all look bad they're
called attorneys general they're
attorneys not generals got
the firm of chuck schumer's radical left
brother
all these never trumpers working
full-time in the prosecutor's office to
get trump
because they couldn't do it before hey
guys are more people leaving is that
what's
are there more people just filing out
we've got to keep an eye on this this is
amazing good time actually
i guess there's something going on
because i do have a good time because
you know what we've done a great job
for america we've done a great job for
this country
but this and other equally bad examples
are what i've been putting up with for
years and despite that we accomplished
more in this presidency than virtually
any other why are the people leaving so
funny of our country
if these radical vicious racist
prosecutors do anything wrong or illegal
i hope we are going to have in this
country the biggest protest we have ever
had in washington dc
in new york in atlanta and elsewhere
because our country and our elections
are corrupt
they're corrupt
[Applause]
i'm trying to save the usa which is in
the worst condition and position that i
believe it has ever been in i don't
think there's ever been a time where we
were so disrespected and laughed at by
the world our leaders are a joke who
have no idea what they're doing and
things remember that global opinion of
the united states has improved
dramatically in every single poll
since donald trump left and joe biden
was inaugurated one
i don't even think joe biden's done that
much but one of the things that's
undeniable is
public opinion of the u.s has improved
dramatically since trump left
except in russia that's absolutely true
russia loved trump we would have had a
deal with iran the sanctions were
killing him we would have they would
have had a deal within one week
after the election we would have had a
deal with iran now they're being tough
with the united states
putin would never have moved troops to
ukraine china would never have even
thought about taking over taiwan i mean
taiwan
that wasn't even going to be discussed
with myself and president xi and watch
what happens after the olympics i'm a
good predictor watch what happens right
after the olympics the idea that china
first started thinking about taiwanese
aggression
when biden got inaugurated is maybe the
stupidest thing trump's ever said and he
said a lot of dumb things hostages
caused death and injury to many people
during the 18 months before the
surrender not one american soldier was
killed under my watch not one
18 months
and i talked with abdul i said don't do
it abdul don't make silk
you're not going to be happy if you do
it not one soldier i talked to him abdul
he's currently the leader too
he made a good deal he got himself 85
billion dollars worth of equipment they
had a parade two months ago down we've
determined that guy's name is not really
abdul right that's just what he says at
one point he said muhammad can you
imagine that 70 000 trucks
700 000 machine guns and
and guns and rifles 700 000 they're now
a major arms dealer they're selling all
of our stuff they'll keep enough for
themselves but they need 1 20th of what
they have
night goggles that's better than what we
have they have the newest model
not even taken out of the boxes
brand new planes brand new helicopters
the best helicopters in the world giving
them to china
so that china can take them apart and
build them in their own fashion giving
them to russia so they can take apart
and re-engineer
china i was withdrawing also we should
have withdrawn after 21 years but we
would have withdrawn with dignity and
with strength
and we wouldn't have been embarrassed we
would have been the opposite
we would have kept bagram the big air
base that we spent billions and billions
of dollars building 25 years ago this
guy's very very sleepy there were points
at which it looked like he was starting
to doze an hour away from the chinese
nuclear weapons plan
and now china will occupy this base
which cost us so much money
we ran without even turning off the
lights we left can you imagine we left
bagram the biggest air force base in the
world longest and most powerful
runways eight feet this this guy
genuinely looks exhausted this guy's
yawning full mouth open yawning these
two guys are this guy's get kind of
getting
bundled up
they make their nuclear weapon wouldn't
it have been nice for us to have kept
that
85 billion dollars worth of equipment
behind including
the dogs they did leave the dogs by the
way you know they tried to say oh we did
so this is what we have we have an
incompetent government that was elected
through a rigged election and they don't
know what the hell they're doing
it's actually amazing that i received
the first time
63 million votes because the press is
corrupt totally corrupt
the press is the enemy of the people
all right you're totally corrupt that's
a fascistic thing to say it's full out
fascist and the first time won the
election and then did much better the
second time was interesting i was being
interviewed by
a new york times reporter
he said what happened the second time i
said well we did much better we got 12
million more votes he said you know come
to think of it it's true actually
but you know when something's rigged it
wouldn't have mattered if i got 25
million more votes that's how bad it was
it would have been impossible to lose if
i had even 63 or 64 the number one
pollster in the country said if you got
64 million votes or 65 million votes
it's not possible that you lose he was
wrong we got 75 million votes and they
stole it they rigged it and it's a
disgrace to our nation we're like a
third world country
and our country is paying the biggest
price in its history dangerous because
we're going to hell and we're going to
hell very fast and we soon
will not have a country left with all
that's happening to
this incredible land of ours by these
radical left crazy people and just
remember this
in one year what they've done to our
country it's not even believable if you
would have said all of these things were
happening with the economy with
inflation with our military with our
woke generals that are
they don't have a clue
with all of the by the way we have great
generals i just want to leave you with
some positive
when i took on
and you have to understand this is very
important because i took on
isis
we took on al baghdadi all the other our
military is incredible
but not the generals that you see on
television those guys are not incredible
and they don't represent our country and
they don't represent who we are as we
speak the radical democrats are
aggressively pushing crap did i take
myself off stream when i went when i
meant to go to the bingo thing
and you wonder why do they want to do
that when they cheated so successfully
in the election right
they don't have a voting rights bill
they have a voting fraud bill that's a
vote this is what i was doing that's a
bill that says
if you pass this there will never be a
republican elected again in this country
that's what that bill says
every senate democrat supports
abolishing voter id in every state
forcing ballot harvesting on every state
forcing unsecured drop boxes on every
state and letting left-wing billionaires
pump dark money into
local election offices so
zuckerberg
417 million you know
if you're involved in politics and if
you give 10 cents more than 5
600
they put you in jail this guy gave
417 million dollars and they're doling
it out all over the country
it's a disgrace
the only possible reason for democrats
to deport such a bill is that they want
to enable cheating and fraud on a
massive scale like you've never seen
before but i think we have seen it
before because i don't believe they
could do it any better or any more than
they did it
in the election of 2020 what when
republicans take over we need to pass
voter id
signature verification
residency confirmation no more unmanned
and unsecured drop boxes
you ever see these drop boxes did you
ever look at the votes that came in the
percentages
they were nice when they gave me one
percent
and no more ballot harvesting no more
ballot harvested that that's a lie
and that's what the law calls for
we should pass that did trump just try
saying that he only got one percent of
all the mail-in vote and thus it was
fraudulent that that's crazy
only american citizens should vote in
american elections
and if it were solely up to me i'd have
one-day elections using only paper
ballots except for military
and seriously ill or disabled people
[Applause]
one day we have these elections they go
on for weeks and weeks the boxes are
sitting in quarters they're moving all
over the place nobody knows what the
hell is going on few people do
how about it does look like there's a
lot of this guy's yawning of a storm now
this guy put a mask on now
this guy also spoke to a woman down here
just a moment ago about whether they
want to get going
i think people are going to start
dropping like flies country
we're just nine months away from what
could be the most important midterm
victory in all of american history great
people including the people that we just
mentioned
our country is at stake ninja and we
need a landslide so enormous that the
radical democrats cannot steal it no
matter what they do that's what we need
if we make it big enough
it gets very very hard
so to every patriot
here today i ask you to get ready to
work all right guys we're going to ban
someone someone just said no one is
leaving you hater they pre-screen the
people behind him they stay till the end
how many people have already left from
behind trump have have we seen eight of
them already leave how many of them have
left so far
people in the chat you guys can explain
it there's been people leaving since at
least 20 minutes ago at least eight an
entire family yeah
and in
2024 should we ban that guy he's just
annoying me that beautiful beautiful
house that happens to be white that is
so magnificent and that we all love we
are going to take back the white house
[Applause]
with a republican congress we will fight
for more jobs for american families fair
trade for american workers and more
american factories forging more products
stamped with that beautiful phrase made
oh is he going directly into the closing
all of a sudden
we will shut down joe biden's border
disaster we will again end catch and
release we will quickly complete the
border wall it will be done in three
weeks we will end chain migration and we
will make sure those he got 50 miles
done in four years and he's going to do
the other 12 what is it 1200 1800 in
three weeks
we will hold china accountable for
unleashing the virus and charge them
trillions of dollars for the damage and
suffering
they have caused and we will
we will end the foreign influence buying
of our corrupt political class and we
will make clear that the government of
the united states is not for sale look
at what's happening
we will break up big tech and we will
restore the right to free speech
in america we will have free speech
again
you know somebody said how do you solve
the problem if we had an honest press
with honest reporters that would go
around and speak the truth it would all
be solved right but we don't have that
it's a much bigger problem than anyone
and nobody knows how corrupt you know if
you're a carpenter you drive a taxi you
you're a wall street purse doesn't
matter
you don't know how dishonest they are
because you know you're not there so
when i speak to a reporter i know what
happened i know what i told the reporter
and when the story comes in totally
different with the exact opposite
meaning
nobody's going to know that but me they
are really corrupt and they're really
bad for the country
and you'll never solve the problem you
have to get honest reporters you have to
get reporting back you have to have
free speech and fair open
newspapers and all forms of medium
what's happening is so big all forms of
medium
not small
not large all
forms of medium important it's going to
destroy our corrupt media is going to
destroy our country if we don't do
something about it we will protect
innocent life we will defend our
constitution we will defend the second
amendment and we will proudly uphold the
judeo-christian values and principles
of our nation's founder
and to finish we will ban critical race
theory in our classes
we will ban it in our military we will
ban it from our workplaces and we will
ban it from our federal state
and local how do you ban critical race
theory from like
i don't know you know a print shop or
something or a factory it was ended and
then he came in and they did an
executive order and they did an unbeaten
i'll do that first day first hour if i
decide to run and if we win
if we win
[Applause]
and another thing we'll do and so many
people have been asking me about it
if i run and if i win
we will treat those people from january
6 fairly
we will treat them fairly
and if it requires pardons we will give
them pardons because they are being
treated so from teasing pardons to the
rioters happened
to all of the other atrocities that took
place recently nothing like this has
happened what that unselect committee is
doing and what the people are doing that
are running those prisons it's a
disgrace it's a disgrace we will treat
them fairly
and we will take care of the people of
this country all of the people of this
country we will fire
the woke generals who only know how to
lose
they only know how to live
it is extraordinarily fascistic he'll
pardon the people who committed violence
at his urging united states out of these
ridiculous foreign wars where they don't
even want us we will ban
men from participating in women's sports
so ridiculous
did you see the man who was on the
swimming team at a certain school that i
know very well
the record held for like 11 years he
beat it by 38 seconds
but the best is the weight lifting
records they're going
one guy walks in with one hand he's
going like this he broke the record that
held up for 20 years
and we were 20 years they're putting a
little half an ounce on each side of the
weights and the women are working so
hard this guy comes in have you lifted
before no oh
wow wow
take a look at the weight lifting
records you want to see some real
think of it
two ounces is unacceptable they beat
them by
many many many many many many pounds we
will restore patriotic education to our
schools
and we will teach our children to love
their country honor our history and to
always respect our great american flag
our maga movement is by far
the greatest political movement in the
history of our country
and i say it all the time and they never
even the fake news they never even
question it because it is there's never
been anything like it and you know what
it really stands for
loving our country that's all it is
together we are standing up against some
of the most sinister forces entrenched
interests and vicious opponents our
people have ever seen could say our
country has never seen anything like it
right but no matter how big or powerful
these corrupt radicals may be
you must never forget our nation does
not belong to them our nation belongs to
you
[Music]
what do you guys think is making this
rally particularly sinister our american
liberty is your
god-given right
from houston to austin
from dallas to el paso
from the red river to the rio grande
the people of texas live and breathe the
fear spirit of independence and the lone
star state has always embraced the cause
of american freedom
like no one else or like no place else
this is the state where william travis
james bowie and davey crockett made
their last stand at the alamo i love the
alabama
this is the state where a small band of
patriots from
the battle of gonzalez
armed with a single cannon
stared down a foreign army that was so
powerful and declared
come and take it
[Music]
and texas is the state
where generations of farmers and this
guy is just barely awake i mean just
just barely hanging on here
prospectors pioneers help build up the
greatest nation in the history of the
world and we will never let any
socialist or communist movement
take that away from us
there is no mountain we cannot climb
there is no summit we cannot reach
there is no challenge we cannot meet
there is no victory we cannot have
because faith is lifting up our souls
american pride is beating in our hearts
and pure
unflinching courage is coursing through
our veins
we will not bend
we will not break we will not yield
we will never give in we will never give
up we will never ever back down
my fellow americans this incredible
journey we are on together has only just
begun
and it is time to start talking about
greatness for our country again
we want to talk about greatness already
we don't want to talk about the things
we've been talking about what have we
been talking about
covet
the environment
the sea is going to rise 100 of an inch
within the next 300 years
woof that is that is really weaponized
for our country
because we are one movement one people
one family and one glorious nation under
god
[Music]
and together we will make america
powerful again
we will make america wealthy again
we will make america strong again
we will make america proud again
we will make
america safe again
we will make america united again
and we will make america great again
thank you texas thank you
[Music]
we will wow
men mexico
[Music]
there it is
wow
as bad as ever
[Music]
another completely weaponized event
completely and totally weaponized uh
yeah we'll keep i'll keep showing super
chats if you guys have thoughts
truly nuts
extremely dangerous and corrosive rally
very very
corrosive um
what can even be said
i mean what's what's crazier that he's
doing the rally or that people are going
to it and clapping right at a certain
point we've got to say
without the people he's just a guy
talking to no one
thanks beerus for the twitch prime sub
appreciate that
thanks to everybody by the way who's
been subscribing today it's been quite
quite an evening
if you're wondering why no one's leaving
now
they usually have to stay for hours
before they're allowed to leave it's
crazy what happened at the last one
man the number of people we've been
banning today it's it's truly crazy
our correspondence will have a ton of
interesting video for me for uh
the monday show
in fact i may have some stuff here
so that's the end of the rally
um
let's just you guys want us i just got a
few interviews from one of our
correspondents this is from josh pitt we
want to look at one
let's see what we got
um
let me see if i can download one
let's just see
uh
just just to see what we can expect
here's some of the stuff
let's see what we got
[Music]
right he's not a scientist though so i
don't know personally
so um
what do you think about his recent
comments about encouraging people to get
vaccinated
are you a fan
i think it's uh i think he wants to get
elected i don't think it's the right
issue but
let's just call me thank you do you
prefer how someone like ron desantis
talks about vaccines instead
i'm a fan
would you like to run in 2024
what is
[Laughter]
oh this is good
this is good
what is it i'm nothing i'm a fan of
that's genius
gotcha
so um
do you think joe biden is a puppy
i don't think he jumped out
together
well so this guy won't answer any
questions that's interesting like
literally he will and he won't
answer any question directly uh let's
see one more
um these are these are from josh pitt
who was on the ground in texas for us
today let's see here's another one and i
i understand the audio is not great
we're going to do what we can with it
[Music]
okay
what do you hope or expect to learn from
donald trump tonight
i just came for the rally because
i don't know man i'm not really happy
with the way things are going right now
in the u.s
i don't think it was like this last year
[Music]
man these are this is like pretty pretty
freaking bad
so are you hoping that he'll
have some kind of new policy or
direction for the country
yeah i'm hoping that if he if he was a
runner game let's say then maybe he
could bring
us together i think
the vast majority of like demographics
their views are changing from
left ideas to a little bit more centered
and i think that's where most people
stand in place
you can center donald trump in the
center
he's like probably center right little
bit more to the right
desantis
we'll get there
are
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
how much credit do you give donald trump
for creating the vaccines
uh pretty sure his administration
got it started enrolling
i'm not sure like the vaccine
[Music]
what do you think about him encouraging
people to
didn't get get
to just recently
i think it's the individual's decision
so
would you vote for donald trump in 2024
do you want him to run
i do want to run
[Music]
like political figures
i think we need real people to stand up
in our community
these are pretty interesting interviews
all right let's see uh let's see one
more here
this is something oh this is the this is
this is the best one right i mean do are
we assuming this is the best one
okay
i believe so
a week
we
wake up
to be against the covenants you know we
fight for america
for americans
you know weak about
america
you know which communist policies has he
supported or enacted
which
josh
if you if you get yeses from people who
say biden's a communist
you ask
what policies josh is doing a really
good job here
i believe that
that the
universal
uh
what we call universal
folks
the what
what was that universal what what what
did he say
[Music]
i don't know what that means
what did biden do universally
what is happening
you know
like
what
what is it that he's doing universal
china i don't even know what he's
talking about
[Music]
global warming
biden's global warming policy is
communist man
if you don't think global warming is
real no not at all created by china
seducing us
go into that
area to clean up what china or soviet
union or the communist bloc created that
that's interesting china created global
warming to trick us to go clean up
environmental messes in their country
that's i've never heard that
for it before you don't want to do it
thank you they created that then they
had to pay for it
oh so you think that they're they're
more responsible for for climate change
yeah so he thinks climate change is real
oh my god yeah i don't believe in
climate change at all okay but if it
does it change
the temperature of the earth
very little nothing we can do about it
you remember
365 days
for a year which includes four seasons
for season
four season right i actually think
unless you have 400 days of the year
it's full-blown socialism
in the universe in a different section
right so
so
the big album
i actually think the oort cloud is
stalinist leninist
season then the earth
travel in flight
universe
uh
one one four of the full circle so each
region in the universe is different
right
and how do you change that
you got to pray to
has
god
idea what's going on but he's doing a
good job all right let's look at the
last one and then i'm i'm about to have
another one from luke which is just
going to be wild
is he holding a stick pretending it's a
microphone that's amazing that's
actually an incredibly great visual
comedy
down here let me get my glasses on
i forgot my makeup you're good let me
know when you're ready got ready all
right hang on
don't ask a hard question that i can't
think of right now i wouldn't be a good
journalist if i didn't ask yeah right
exactly right
okay so thank you for the microphone by
the
way
so here we go
what do you expect or hope to learn
tonight new information from donald
trump
oh the new information that i hope to
learn tonight would be
uh i want him to say that he's running
i'm just confirming but i think there's
a certain date that he has to confirm
that by so oh he can't say anything yet
so i'm not sure if we're out that date
or not okay but if he is he needs to see
it right here in texas right here in
conroe texas texas and um
that things are just moving along like
they should like we should go where we
should go in the future
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i did she say i have coveted right now
hold on a second i've got to hear that
again
okay
so
are you yourself vaccinated
no i had covered she's she's saying i
have covet isn't she isn't she saying i
have coveted
like if i look at her mouth i'm not
seeing the
had i'm seeing have
let's just look at it once more
and i want my immune system and i'll
fast make that even stronger no
absolutely not and my son's not and
nobody is she fasted to make her immune
system stronger
do you think donald trump created the
vector i'm vaccinated as far as
that shot that shot's not a vaccine
okay okay so do you think donald trump
created that shot
he didn't create the shot
he had the professionals that have that
job the scientists so called that's
their job sure why would trump create a
fake vaccine right
and he made that happen and if they
screwed that up that's on them through
operation workspeed absolutely
he created warp speed they're the signs
that create the shot
president trump did not so what do you
think about his comments just recently
encouraging people to be vaccinated
encouraging people to get their booster
well he i mean he that's what he that's
what he what did warps me he doesn't
know or has confirmed or has the
information or he does but
you know i would think he does
but
everybody's out there to make their own
decision sure so trump's promoting a
fake vaccine that he knows doesn't work
so that's what he's given free will you
make your decision
her as american you can get and they
shut down the pro for lactic so there's
that average in hydrocorticon he did
hydro corrigan that's like billy corgan
hydro corgan he did and he showed the
way they shut all that down everybody
has the right to make a decision that's
it so for him saying whatever he i mean
that's what he said
they shut down corgis is that what she
said that's that's crazy yeah fascinated
booster doesn't bother me
i don't know what he was boosted or
vaccinated with got it you don't either
i don't i just know there's that i know
you took heart to corporate
there's that right right so other than
that yeah i mean we don't know what his
was made like well i have no idea okay
fair enough so do you think joe biden is
communist yes
yes
yes he's so up in the china it is not
even funny so based on what policy that
he supports would you consider to be
communist
what what do you mean say that again are
there any followers it's interesting how
that question is really confusing to
everybody it's like well what do you
what do you mean policy
what does that mean
he's that he's enacted or supported
well he supports china and that just
sums it all up right there supports
trump okay so the china president the
china not the chinese people that are
being brutalized and hurt
he supports the chinese he's been in
their pockets and that's not going to
change and they're the communist china
pretty much chinese communist party said
that much pretty much everything that
there you go absolutely his son is in
bed i mean you can't we can go on and on
and on about that are you concerned he
needs to be he's a treason he needs to
be in prison he's just trying or hung
like back in the day
there you
so um do you think uh
donald trump should run again
yeah absolutely i think you said that i
think i think he's still running
because it's not over the election
so that's that and then i've got one
more here let me see how i can
let me see how i can get this for you
guys i have one more
this one's from luke now
um
these this is really something else
we're gonna have to do this with more
rallies i have to tell you guys
um
let's check this one out
see if i can get this here so this is
luke with a guy let's see
on a quick nomination keep going but um
i'm guessing vaccine you're not that
i've seen uh no no the vaccine is dna
altering mrna messenger rna it sees the
meshes that alters your rna of your
deoxyribonucleic acid anyone that takes
that for a bogus vaccine is a certified
jackass
oh my gosh so we're here and if you've
asked your children who don't even get
corona you're gonna answer the guy
okay and we're here at trump rally and
he encourages people to get it does that
upset you
yeah um uh he's uh probably not taking
it i think he's got so trump's lying
that he got it that's interesting
trump got sailing like trump didn't even
do it publicly so why would he have to
get saline he wouldn't he could just lie
you don't need to get a fake vaccine to
claim you got it if you didn't
i think he's lying
putin said he took it too and a lot of
his top people announced that he didn't
then he was like why is trump trying to
put that vaccine at people there um
probably money and also he wants to
claim that he
saved the world
so let's see trump is encouraging the
vaccine that he didn't really get
so that other people get it so he gets
money
and saves the world but the vaccine
doesn't work so it wouldn't save the
world
you guys following this
but you support himself
uh we don't have any choice right now
and uh desantis also took the backs and
uh so i don't know who's gonna
he's gonna run but i'm hoping it was
just trump we have to vote for him okay
because he's the only one that's
anti-mandate but he's the priority if
someone ran against trump who was
against the vaccine you would prefer him
well if god or i would prefer whoever
runs against him that's andy vice hasn't
taken it but they have to be as good of
the statesman as trump is and that's not
likely it's tough yeah that'll be really
really difficult it'll be really
difficult to find someone as as good as
a statesman as trump is that's tough
that will be very tough it looks like
we're gonna have no choice but to vote
for him he's never been a mandate okay
wow
what a very nice job here very very nice
job
um if you guys want to follow luke luke
has his own youtube channel it's luke
beasley youtube.com luke beasley and he
has picked up a few hundred subscribers
today thanks to his great work for us
you could find that there
uh also thanks to josh pitt and we're
gonna be going through all of these all
of these
videos for monday
um and i think we should do this again
we should do this again at the next
trump rally we'll announce if people
wherever it's going to be if people live
nearby i think we absolutely need to do
this these are some really good young
people doing some really really great
stuff and um we're supporting them out
of
uh the contributions that come into the
stream so by all means plea and i will
suggest at least a kn 95 for the guys
going forward
please please please make sure you get
those uh
twitch prime subs in and sign up at
joinpakman.com in the entire thing all
right everybody that's gonna do it for
this stream i really appreciate
everybody joining me
what an insane rally and we'll have news
soon about the next one get those free
covet tests covettest.gov
and uh we'll see you guys monday thank
you